What's bad?
Stevia,
the Joe Rogan experience
podcast by
looking at a Tom Papa.
He wants over this.
You know what this is?
Is Bulletproof coffee bulletproof?
The idea behind it is that.
Is there any in there?
Yeah.
I feel so cold.
No,
it's not.
Don't worry.
It's just.
It's coffee that's blended with
grass fed butter and MCT oil once.
It's actually.
It's a very conscious.
It looks milky.
It's delicious.
The guy who invented it
was a guy named Rob Wolf,
but the guy who popularized it as kind
of a nutty dude that had a lot of false
claims about the benefits of it.
If you want some of this Stevia stuff,
this is actually pretty,
pretty Yummy,
but you've got to use very little of it.
It's very sweet,
but it has no sugar in it.
It's a natural sweetener.
Is there milk in this?
It's butter.
Butter is butter.
Grass fed butter blended in with mct oil.
Mct Oil is a medium chain triglyceride.
Oil Oil.
It's the most,
the healthiest aspects of coconut oil.
They're spun in a centrifuge and then
it's extracted and then they take that and
they blended in with the coffee.
This is why I love you,
Joe Rogan.
Why
doesn't.
This is why this kind of stuff,
whenever I listen to you,
but whenever I listened to you,
you can know more about
this kind of stuff you like.
When I listened to you
say stuff like that,
I'm like,
what do I do with my time?
I need to read more.
So is this is black coffee?
No,
it was black,
but then it's blended in with this.
Gotcha.
Medium tree.
It mean that.
I don't know what's in that.
They're all.
They're all bulletproof,
right?
None of it's black.
It tastes good like it.
It's Yummy.
Coffee to coffee.
Me Too.
When I go to sleep at night,
I get so excited like,
oh,
I'm going to close my eyes
now and when I opened them,
it's gonna be coffee time again.
Really?
That's bizarre.
Dude.
You might want to look into that.
Do you ever take time off of coughing?
No.
Not Interested in that.
No,
no,
no.
I'm not fighting it like A.
I was like,
maybe I shouldn't have
it in the afternoon.
No.
Well,
it's.
There's a lot of things,
false,
false ideas that people have about
the negative aspects of coughing.
It's not really that bad for you.
It's not right now.
It's a dehydrating element.
It has a diuretic effect,
but you just drink water,
be right.
I need energy.
I need to get through all day and night,
but the problem is with some people that
stresses their adrenals can drink too
much coffee.
It's like many things.
You know,
you can't.
You go overboard.
Yeah.
If you have too much salt,
that will fucking kill you.
I mean,
look,
if you eat a pound of salt,
you're a dead man right now.
Yeah,
no,
that's how I feel.
I feel like we're grown ups now and there
are things that are kind of vices and
you have to them like drinking.
I'm not going to drink
like I did when I was 25.
I drink like a,
like a grownup,
like a gentleman,
5:00 comes,
Martini Shaker,
one cocktail.
That's it.
Who's getting hurt?
No one's getting hurt.
Matter of fact,
they've shown that a glass of wine a day
is actually as healthy as exercise for
some people.
Really.
Who were those?
Some people.
How do you know if you want to something?
Oh,
you probably most.
I think the idea behind
a glass of wine is,
first of all,
there's resveratrol in it,
which is a,
um,
a natural antioxidant that comes from
grapes and exists in wine and it's
actually very good for her.
I actually take it as a
supplement because Charles,
very good for you.
But,
and then on top of that,
there's a certain amount of
benefit in a stress relieving the,
the,
the wind hits you and you're like,
ah.
And that calmness and strength,
it's very hard to,
under or over emphasize
how important that is.
Huge.
It's a massive,
huge.
Now I have a,
I do yoga and it's
primarily because of that.
Yeah.
When I'm not doing it,
my stress level is so much higher.
It's not the stress levels.
Stress is always the same.
My life is my life,
but it just kind of rolls off
when I'm really active with it.
You just kind of rolls off.
Manageable,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
Smoke weed.
Yeah,
there you go.
It is good for you.
I've kind of.
This is what I've cut back.
I know.
Well I know I'm coming back.
Coming back to weed.
Yeah.
I got some right here.
If you want to find one of these bad boys.
I don't know.
I got to drive.
Scared to drive.
I'm.
This is.
Yeah.
I am scared.
You know what it is.
I have a friend who's an older guy,
comedian talking about me now.
You're young man.
This guy,
he's gay and that's definitely not me,
bro.
Came up.
He came up during the,
during the time when
people weren't out right.
And now everybody's out.
But because he grew up during that
time and he's pretty much out.
He still like shaky.
Like he doesn't.
He's still scared.
Like he will speak in hushed tones about
certain stuff because that's how we
grew up.
That's how I feel with weed I came up
with was illegal and you're paranoid all
the time and trying to sneak it.
I'm 46,
so you're a year younger than me.
That's ridiculous.
Yeah.
I'm 47.
Are you really smoke it son?
Don't be scared or this is what I
smoked up until I guess like maybe,
I don't know,
five years after college,
six years maybe something like a
good 10 year block of all the time.
And then,
uh,
I wasn't as funny.
I wasn't as,
I really wasn't,
I,
it was taking away my funny and uh,
so I put it down and stayed away
for a pretty long time and uh,
I've been a comedian for 20 years,
so like 10 years of it I was doing it
and then last 10 and I haven't been doing
it and uh,
just in the last year or two,
I'm like,
I'm bringing it back in.
Just been the last year or two.
Yeah.
What?
And it was,
was it a pragmatic decision,
like a funny decision?
Um,
yeah,
it's,
it's pretty thought.
Yeah.
It's pretty thoughtful.
Like I,
I stopped because there was this kid
that I used to in high school I used to
riff with all the time
we would get together.
He wasn't,
was just an Irish naturally funny,
you know,
like naturally Irish,
those guys that could just curse,
like nobody could and just hilarious and
the two of us would always get together
at these parties and we would just screw
around and everyone would be laughing
and you know,
we're riffing together and it was great.
And so I went away and came back one time
in college and it was high and we met
up at a party and he just
ran circles around me.
I completely didn't have it.
I was like,
Duh,
because you're too.
I was too high.
And uh,
I always thought about that.
And then as I was going along it was like,
it wasn't as productive.
It wasn't as funny.
It just wasn't,
wasn't working for me.
So I just completely put it down and then,
you know,
worked on my comedy and did everything
that I wanted to do as a comedian.
And now the same thing as the alcohol,
like a gentleman,
I know how to smoke,
now I know how to drink the,
you know what I mean?
So I kind of bring it back and
especially I really use it,
especially when I'm writing when.
Yeah,
I always at least have
a notebook around me.
You know,
don't like to smoke socially.
No,
no,
you get weird.
Um,
yeah.
I get a little weird right now.
I'm always weird.
I always feel weird.
I always had a great quote
they asked her about.
She's gone to Coachella
and the asked her a,
are you going to get high or whatever.
She's like,
do you know I do this.
I do that.
Well,
you get high there.
She's like,
I don't know.
She goes,
I have a rule.
I never get high.
If I have to pretend that I'm not.
Isn't that great?
That really hit home for me.
I'm like,
there's so many.
I don't want to be like,
no,
I'm not.
I'm okay.
Yeah.
You should never lie about being high.
Look,
people do.
It's like people lie about
three things on a regular basis.
They lie about being high.
They lie about whether or not they were
awake when you called them and they lie.
Whether or not they forwarded three things
that are super common that people lie
about.
I was just with a friend of mine.
Uh,
I'll say his name,
Danny,
the guy who runs largo and uh,
we were just having coffee this morning
and we're the only two people outside
any foreign fucker.
I mean,
like a big cabbage fart
planning.
He's like,
I didn't do it.
Yes you did.
Was even if it was mine and it
snuck out and I wasn't aware.
My never smell like
big Scottish and Irish.
He completely lied right to face.
And then when we were
saying goodbye at the,
at the,
uh,
parking meters,
the smell came up again and I just let
it go and when he's not going to come to
some people,
some people would just fart all over.
You smoked the whole time.
Did you smoke all the way through?
Did you pick up weed later on?
I picked up when I was 30.
When you were 30.
So last 17 years.
See,
that's healthy because
your brain was already.
You were already Joe Rogan.
I had a bad idea of it though.
My idea of weed was a
weed was bad for you.
My idea was that we'd was just,
uh,
you know,
was,
it was a crutch and it was
for weak minded people.
You know,
I had this,
I had a lot of misconceptions about pot.
Yeah,
I picked it up.
I guess I want to see what year was it?
Um,
it was,
yeah,
it was somewhere around 2000.
What was your first time?
Was it a big deal?
It was your first time.
Um,
you have this probably before 2000 now
let's think about it because it was
before y two k because I was
high when y twoK was happening,
was terrified.
It's all going down really happening.
Um,
my ideas were about,
were all wrong and they are all
based on people being losers.
Yeah.
There's also based on just
the idea of drugs themselves,
I had grown up around quite a few people
that had drug problems and especially
with coke,
which I'd never have done.
Yeah.
And it's because of that.
It's because of seeing these
people like their lives,
like get devastated by this drug.
So I was a,
I was terrified of it all.
Drugs I felt like made you a loser.
Yeah.
Well it's not.
Yeah,
I mean if you're around it and you see it,
I didn't think that,
uh,
it was so much loser thing
and I don't at this point,
I do think you can start too early.
I do think as a parent,
I'm saying this in case my children's
friends listened to the show and then tell
my daughter.
But uh,
but I do think like at a certain,
like if you can start to early,
everyone I know who started too early
got a little weird if you spun out a
little bit,
but your brain has to kind of become you.
You're so just to figure
out who you are and what,
you know,
your brain is really hyper developing
then like why mess with it?
Yeah.
I think you're taking like a real big,
like you take a big leap from your normal
consciousness when you're getting high
and we just sort of getting the
feel of your normal consciousness.
If you're getting high all the time,
it can miss out on a developmental period.
Completely,
very confusing period.
And Lynn,
why throw that into it?
Yeah,
no,
I completely agree.
I think that there's certain amount of
people especially that should never try
weed.
It's not for them.
Not at all.
Did you feel like by the time
you were 30 when you started,
like you kind of were done with all
of figuring out who you were kind of
weirdness or were you,
um,
no real figuring out who I am?
I think will.
You're always.
I think if you really are
not growing as a person,
you're,
you're basically dead in the water,
right?
I mean it's A.
I'm not perfect.
No one's perfect.
So if you're not perfect,
you're constantly trying to improve
on various aspects of your life.
And as a comic,
especially when you
abandoned your material,
like you have an act,
you put out a special and then
you toss all your material out,
you're starting fresh.
You kinda got to reinvent like what
your thoughts are reinventing you.
Definitely reinventing what
you're presenting on stage.
Yeah.
So there's this constant sort of cycle
or developmental period where you go
through,
you,
you put out the Special Yuh,
Yuh Yuh,
Yuh Yuh.
It too is,
is fine an edge as you think that you
can and then you release it and then you
go,
okay,
let's start all over again.
When you're starting all over again.
There's a lot of thinking involved.
That's why those old
guys that never wrote.
Yeah,
there was a period like,
yeah,
we've all seen those guys that have
the same act from 20 years ago.
Scary.
Those poor bastards,
they become irrelevant.
They really quick.
They,
they die,
die in their mind.
Their mind is dead.
Dead.
Like you see them on stage
telling those old jokes,
you know,
like fucking Christ man.
Yeah.
There was a guy that came into
the improv not too long ago.
It was doing Oj jokes if,
unless it's a really good Oj joke.
I mean,
you never know.
It wasn't like that.
A guy has a new take on an old story.
Oh,
that old yarn.
But it was like.
So you guys heard about Oj,
right?
You think he was guilty.
But we're so self aware as Comedians,
you're always looking at yourself,
analyzing yourself,
you know what I mean?
We're,
we're kind of hyper aware.
We,
you kind of have to.
Otherwise you can bomb.
You ever have like a big thing happen in
your life and you go back on stage and
you're like,
oh,
I'm a different guy than the
guy that wrote this stuff.
Oh definitely.
You know what I mean?
Well that's the beautiful thing about
getting rid of your act every couple of
years or at least doing a new specialist
starting from scratch every couple of
years.
So you can kind of represent
who you are right now.
Right.
You know,
I'll go back and listen to like
my first CD from 1999 Christ.
It's hard.
Any leads that was like
a CD on warner brothers,
like a real cd.
Like I can go back and listen
to recordings before that.
Fucking God awful.
You had to go back and do your own
act from your first couple of years.
Oh my God.
What's amazing to me,
and I always think about is people were
hiring me when I was telling me stokes
and like I was making money with this act.
It was so bad.
Well,
if you went to any comedy
club across the country,
you see various stages of
development and you're always gonna.
See that?
I remember really clearly like struggling
and trying to put it together and then
go into see someone
really good and be like,
fuck.
Never getting there.
Yeah.
This is never happening.
I know it makes you almost want to quit.
I know,
you know it has been doing that
to me lately as a Maria Bamford.
I watched her ran into her a couple
times and she was just so prolific in
writing so much in such good
stuff and I was just like,
it's good.
It's like you go,
all right,
let me look at my material.
Hm,
what am I cheating on?
Getting labs with this whole act,
but what am I really?
What am,
what am I mugging?
What am I,
where is there not really a solid idea
or solid joke and you start looking at
you like,
all right,
I'm,
I'm cheating here.
That's a good line here is.
I don't know why they're laughing at this.
Maybe it was my funny face when I say it,
you know what it's like to really
kind of look at it and analyze it.
It's like this is kind of
cheating 80 percent of the time.
Well that's why like,
you know,
being inspired by your peers.
It's one of the good things about being
in a big comedy community like New York
or is it you get to be around like all
these high level comics on a regular
basis and you sorta can compare
yourself to them completely.
This is why I'm psyched to be here and I
really am very happy to be here because
I've been a fan of yours for a long,
long time and we never
really never really hung out.
We never really is.
It's a big sea of comedy.
If we could both be in it
for that long and not really
see each other,
you know what I mean?
That's a big pool.
Well,
there's a lot of places to go.
You know,
how many we've been having
this discussion lately.
How many comics do you think
there are in this country?
Like working professional
comedians who actually,
that's what they do.
It's their only gig or
if they're only Gig,
they're like real headliners,
like the tomato of a TV
show or something like that,
but there are legit,
you know,
or you know,
a middle act and make their living.
They can make their living off comedy.
Yeah.
I'm going to say a real pro,
a real pro thousand.
I'm going to go a little higher.
Really?
Yeah.
Good for you.
There's a lot of gigs at.
I'm really bad at math,
but then wait a minute.
How many as a thousand fingers out?
Uh,
yeah,
because I mean think about
every single night there's,
there's gigs happening everywhere.
Every stupid town.
There's some bar,
some corporate gigs,
some theater show,
some something going on.
Yeah.
But a lot of those I wouldn't
even think are real comics.
They're just like the
best that that city has.
You know,
they're not really like
touring like that same time.
It's probably not going
to like Indiana next week.
And then like,
you know,
Florida that does have.
But they are pro comics.
Like there's like you've always talk
about Boston having all those local
professional communities that never left,
that are,
were undeniably pros.
Yeah.
I guess I don't think
it's maybe a thousand.
That's a lot.
Silat thousands of
out of that thousand.
Okay.
Let's call it a thousand.
Out of that thousand,
how many are good?
200.
200 are good.
Yeah.
I would say that's about right.
And then,
you know,
you've got to add,
there's,
you know,
there's a variability based on
taste and subjective thinking.
Sure.
But you know,
you know when someone's good.
Yeah.
I mean,
but what,
you know,
what I might think is good.
I might have a higher standard and some,
some I've been,
have had people tell me,
this guy's really funny.
You should see them then.
I've got black guys.
Fucking dog.
Shit.
This is terrible.
I can't watch this.
Yeah,
yeah.
But then there's other guys
that you see and you're like,
alright,
I get it.
It's not for me,
but I get that he's right.
Turning a lot of people on.
He's not horrible.
I just don't want to listen to it.
Well,
there's some people that are
like really good performers,
you know,
and they just fucking dollop
something that's really not there.
Right.
You know,
it's called cheap laughs.
Built on fake energy.
Yeah.
What does,
you know?
There's,
there's something to be learned.
Even from that.
I mean that's one of the things that I
always used to say about Carlos when ceos
that I never understood
why people were laughing,
but it was amazing.
The energy that he put out,
you get the.
I'd never got it,
like roads,
like sit there like dead face going,
what the fuck is happening here?
But there they were all caught up in this
energy and momentum of the blah blah,
blah,
blah.
All this shit that was going on.
And I was like,
wow,
this is crazy.
Like there are guys that
have that sort of like big,
loud,
fake thing where they don't really give
a fuck about what they're talking about
new.
But they're kind of.
It's closer to politicians.
And they are comedians.
Yeah.
They know how to turn it on the crowd.
They know how to work it.
But there's a clause for the ladies.
Ladies are working hard out there.
Gentlemen,
come on.
How about a round of
applause for those ladies?
But one for the troops.
Can we get one of
these?
That's those.
Those like really strategic
things that people will say.
They'll say things where you go,
oh,
you whore,
you fucking whore.
Oh the ladies really have it hard.
Am I right ladies?
Oh,
the worst is though when you're.
Especially if you're in showcase clubs,
you're wondering like eight
guys that night and it's like,
oh,
they're telling me I gotta go.
I gotta go,
guys are giving me the lag.
No,
please stay there telling
me I gotta go up there.
Really politicians,
a lot of that.
Yeah.
It kind of slick.
But you kinda gotta be a little bit,
right?
You've got to kind of get
people to like you a little,
especially if you want to push forth
and he really controversial idea.
You're going to kind of
sneaking in on them somehow.
Yeah.
Like what we were talking about earlier,
wound full of sugar.
Well we were talking about earlier where
you were saying that because it's so
easy to criticize comedians these days,
so many people go after people
for controversial jokes.
You were talking about how these
young guys you're seeing onstage,
young gals as well are saying jokes,
but there's still like before say it,
they had
to say,
look,
you know I am not racist.
Yeah.
I watched.
I watched five guys in front of me at
the Improv in la go up and these are all
young guys and they're all coming up.
They don't really have much credit,
but they're working.
They've got spot at the Improv and
every anything that came up with,
if it was about race
or religion or gender,
they would apologize before the joke.
I'm like,
Oh shit.
It's gotten to this level.
Everyone's now scared.
We're gonna,
we're gonna be Improv.
There's probably 50 people
in the audience tops.
No.
You know what I mean?
It's nothing you should
have if you're not free now,
when,
what?
All it takes is one blogger,
tom.
Well,
there's this thing at the comedy store
that they do every Tuesday night called
the roast battle.
Have you ever seen it?
I haven't.
I've heard about it.
It's really funny.
Yeah.
Really Fun because they
do it in the belly room,
which is this tiny little room.
They pack it with people and
it's an insult competition,
so right joke writing competition between
two comics and the insult each other
and the the audience and the
judges sort of get to decide who,
who wrote the better stuff and
they go hard at each other.
They fucking go hard,
but somebody wrote an article because a,
someone white dropped an end bomb
during during the show and they're like,
you know,
are white people getting the n word pass
at the comedy store and they wrote this
already,
like you fucking piece of shit.
Like you know what they're doing
exactly what they're doing.
They weren't.
First of all,
they weren't calling
someone who was saying like,
this guy's a nigger,
you know,
they weren't doing that.
They were using the word in the context
of some sort of a joke and even if.
Right.
Yeah,
but it was just like the idea that it
can't be done like this is fuck you right
now this it's comedy.
Like there are things
that are said in comedy.
Look,
yeah,
in real life,
in real speech,
when you're talking to people,
it's probably not the best thing to say.
It's probably a rude thing to say,
of course,
but as a comedian in a club
doing what you're doing,
the only way it's gonna go
away is if you don't fight it,
if you don't resist it,
which is difficult,
but if they come at you and say,
you're,
you're racist for saying this,
you just.
The only comment is I'm a comedian,
and then that's it.
End of story.
It's when you fight
back and you give them,
you take the bait and it become.
If it fuels it and that's
what's been happening,
so now people think,
oh,
I can get this famous guy
to Apollo to apologize,
doesn't make news and be a part of it.
Not really fight back,
but really like sort of defend it.
I mean,
not even defend it.
Apollo fighting back is important I think,
or at least stating your,
your,
your mind speaking your opinion,
but this idea of apologizing for jokes,
fuck off
those people,
the people who write about it,
who are in the audience and taking
a fence in writing that they,
to me are much more
offensive than a comedian.
The comedian is.
He says this man,
his is to make a joke.
That's his job is to make light of things.
And if you're in the audience and you're
calling someone a racist or you're
calling someone,
massage dentist or whatever label,
you are much more violent
than the clown up on stage.
Much more violent,
more violent,
and more about your,
you're provoking.
You're much more offensive,
much more offensive.
But I,
and I,
and violence is close to the term
because I did a show for our good friend.
Uh,
Greg Fitzsimmons was like a fundraiser
thing for the school thing and I was
talking about,
I have this joke in my act
where I say I live in La,
it's a,
it's a horrible school
district that we're,
that we live in and either had to pay for
school or pay for guns and Ammo and my
kids have no skills.
So I pay for school and the only rule
I have school if I'm going to pay for
school is a,
it cannot be predominantly Asian.
Why?
Why would I pay all that money for
my kids to be last in everything.
And then I talk about these families,
how they're just superior.
Asian families are superior.
They work harder.
They want their kids to,
when they play five different instruments.
My kids play the toilet paper roll on
and on and this woman yells out from the
crowd,
get some new material in the middle of it.
Everyone else is laughing.
Get some new material as.
I'm sorry,
what?
She goes,
it's racist.
You're a racist,
I've never been called
a racist in my life,
and it was like,
whoa.
It was kind of like being
punched in the face and I said,
I'm sorry,
are you not listening
to the guy next door?
He goes,
we're wondering where
you're going with this.
The Guy Friend,
he's with her,
he must be with her.
So I'm leaning on the side,
just stop and lean on the stool.
And I said,
where am I going with this?
I'm pointing out that a Asian families,
uh,
work harder than a traditional
American white families.
They work harder and hold their kids
to a higher standard and the therefore
they're excelling more in sports and
they're excelling more in schools because
of how they're raising their,
held to these high standards and that
they are actually doing better for their
families and we are giving our kids a
free pass and making sure that they have a
good time.
But of course this all would have been
done through jokes and would have been
much more enjoyable experience for the
rest of the audience if you had shut up.
I said,
I'm sorry,
what part?
Just so I understand
what race are you?
What part did you,
are you white?
Are You Asian?
She goes,
I'm Mexican.
I said,
alright,
I can't help you.
You're wrong,
and everybody applauded.
The rest of the place applauded,
but I mean her calling me a racist.
I'm telling you,
Joe,
I was.
I went up and did a Neil Brennan show
after that in Santa Monica and then drove
home to my
place in the valley after that
and I was buzzing the whole time,
like by the time I got in,
like I was angry,
angry and the end and kind of hurt.
But you went into a moron.
I ran into a mormon,
but just that term of
having someone say racist,
what?
There's a lot of people
recreationally offended.
They're looking to be offended
whether it makes sense or not,
you know?
It's like saying black
guys have bigger dicks,
racist writing,
so that was a racist to be awesome.
How's it racist?
To be better as a racist,
to be better at math.
You say the Asians are better
at school because it's racist.
It's racist to mock their eyes or say
they were inferior race that's racist,
racist to compliment a race
exactly opposite of racist,
sort of racist against
your own kids there.
So there was so much fun in a time when
you could just talk about each other and
enjoy it.
Like really be like he'd be like,
we were Italian and my friends were
Irish and everybody had their things and
you're celebrating.
You're celebrating that stuff.
My parents generation
really celebrated it,
you know,
now you can't even say what they are
without it being perceived as awful.
I had this Mexican lady yelled at me once.
I had this joke about,
uh,
the,
the Ufo that supposedly
crashed and Roswell,
New Mexico in 1947.
There was this,
the cover of the Roswell Times
or whatever the newspaper was.
I actually have it framed in my house
that the cover of this newspaper,
it said there was a headline that was
like flying disc recovered like that.
They have flying saucer mean.
They wrote about it in the paper.
They had these statements from military
people that they had found crashed ufo.
And then the next day
they came out and said,
sorry,
say the joke was they said they had a
crashed Ufo and alien bodies and then the
next day they came out and they printed
in the paper or they came and had a
press release.
It said,
I don't remember how this joke was.
It was a long time ago.
They said,
oh,
we're sorry.
It was just a weather balloon.
And I said,
well what about the aliens?
Those are Mexicans.
Apparently they were,
they were on the balloon.
They thought it was a pen,
Yada.
They had been drinking,
some shenanigans took place.
And this lady was yelling at me,
hey,
I go,
what did I say?
And she goes,
because I said the word Mexican,
I go like alien,
like another country,
get aliens from another country.
Illegal aliens.
That's what they're called,
right?
So it's Mexican,
Exactly.
But she was like,
you shouldn't be fucking
to make it fun of Mexicans.
And I was like,
well,
why not?
Like,
what are you saying?
what did I say?
Bad?
Just fucking talking shit.
Like,
oh,
okay,
you shouldn't be.
You're too dumb to be here.
They should have made you fill out a
form before you walked through the door.
You fucking dope.
Exactly.
If they were to describe what
was happening in this club,
it was a series of people getting
on stage and talking shit.
The old.
So we went to this whole
back and forth thing.
What does this make sense?
Do Mexicans drink?
Yes,
they do write everybody.
A lot of people drink that are Mexicans.
There's nothing wrong with.
I drink to.
Do Mexicans have a history?
A long history of the pin.
Jada?
Yes,
they do.
They do.
They beat those fucking things.
Candy comes out.
It's well documented.
Why you talking?
Shit.
Do you think it's going to swing back,
do you think?
Yeah,
I hope so.
Don rickles junior's going to show up
and I just think people are just getting
smarter overall.
More edge I may think.
I think there's always going to be.
There's no doubt about it that there are
people that's their mind does not work
as well.
Just like there's kids that are
fucking two and they got big glasses.
What is that?
Well,
their eyes don't work so fucking good.
Some people are born deaf.
I have a friend who was born deaf.
There's just the reality of the world.
There's some people's minds
are just not that good.
Yeah,
no,
there's.
Yeah,
there's no doubt about it.
Oh,
it's physical.
It's reality.
Chemical makeup,
big noses.
Some people.
Some people are fucking shitty brains.
Right?
Why are you shitting on?
There's no way around it,
man.
You're always going to get dumb people.
I,
I do this joke
and make fun of Italians,
which I am recorders.
Italian and I had this guy
yelling at him and it'll fool.
Can Be shooting on toe and I'm like,
I'm shitting on my own people.
Fuck you.
Right?
Like what are you talking
about Mike talking about you?
Yes I am.
You know why?
Because you're doing
exactly what it was saying.
You're yelling.
Fuck it.
It's just that.
Those are real people.
It's not all Italians.
God Damn.
There's millions of them.
But this whole thing like they're
intelligent people though that kind of
provoked this.
Don't you think?
Like there's equal writing editorials
and educated people who want to control
human behavior by semantics,
by,
by kind of they're going to set up
their own rules and you're gonna have to
abide by them.
Well,
there's a lot of people that are unhappy
and they have a green light to start
talking shit,
and there's also people that are bloggers
that are looking for a subject that
they can legitimately find a reason
to attack and they might not.
If they weren't bloggers,
they might not have even focused on it,
but because of the fact
that it's a subject,
it's like,
do I really give a fuck
about Kim Kardashian?
And no,
I do not.
I really don't care.
But if I'm looking for a joke
and she does something stupid,
I'm like,
all right,
bitch,
sit down in front of the
computer and I concoct a bit.
I mean,
this is life,
this culture,
that's this.
I mean,
you can't fault them in some
ways because it is what they do,
but there's a really asinine
viewpoint when you're,
you know,
you're,
you're looking at jokes and you're
trying to pretend that this person is in
court giving an affidavit and these are
their actual thoughts on these subjects.
You know,
there's got to be.
And I think it's,
I think that's the,
just the responsibility of the
comedians at the end of the day.
You've just got to stick to it.
Well,
do you remember when patrice o neal,
he was on this thing.
It was a Fox News show and it was
back when opie and Anthony got fired.
They got suspended I guess,
and he said he was a
really important point.
You said jokes that you are offended by
and jokes that you love all come from
the same place.
Someone's just trying to be funny,
like you don't understand that
because you don't understand funny,
right?
They're just trying to
make you laugh and some,
some of them hit and some of them
met and that's just the way it goes.
And that's the scary part is that you're
in a club trying to make it hit and as
you're working out material
you'll say stuff just working.
It's going to take six months before
this joke is even ready and people are
taping you two weeks in when it's ugly
and you don't really know what you're
saying.
Blurting stuff out.
That's dangerous.
Well,
you know Chris Rock has
that world famous joke,
one of his best jokes ever
that I love black people,
but I hate niggers.
It was a bit.
Well apparently Louis told me
that that bit took a year to work.
Oh yeah.
He used to bomb.
It just wasn't working.
And if someone had been the
audience youtubing that at
the beginning when it was
eating Dick Stage,
he would have looked like
an asshole right now.
Yeah.
And tell people no,
just stick with me.
It's going to be funny.
At one point talking about
it and not only that,
but their joke gets released.
It gets online and it's like,
which is really kind of a violation of
what a comic is doing by working out a
set.
If you see someone at the seller,
if you see someone at the comedy store,
at the Improv,
most of the time,
most of the time you see a
comedian like you are like me.
We're working out stuff.
That's what we're doing.
This is our gym.
It's our workshop.
It's how these things.
When you.
When you see it on comedy central
or if you see it in a headline club,
you see what the Irvine
Improv on a weekend.
Then you're seeing essentially
a finished product,
but all that other stuff is like,
that's how bits get work done.
We need an audience and I've done a lot
of them that don't fucking own man and
then one day they do.
Have you ever been on stage doing this
stupid set in town and just say something
completely,
just come to you like that retard or mean.
I said something horrible about
my wife's tits or something.
It just kind of blurted it
out like I don't think that.
I'm just trying to be funny.
Right,
exactly.
You're just spitball and you're trying
to and people will get angry at you about
the contents of your imagination.
It's like you don't understand,
this is not,
this is performance,
this is not me as a human being given
you my well thought out and clearly
analyzed views on life,
right?
I'm.
Look,
if you're a writer,
any great writer,
greatest of the greats,
take updike,
whoever you,
when you read their stuff,
you're not reading a first draft,
you're reading the 50th draft,
them going to work on this thing and a
comedian is showing you as first draft
every time,
every time he's up there,
like until you go see those big
shows already should fear has quote
that he has taped above his
keyboard from hemingway,
says the first draft
of everything is Shit.
It's great.
It means everything.
It means everything already.
Lang got in trouble recently.
I don't know if you've
been paying attention,
paying attention to that.
Yeah.
I saw him.
I saw him right after he had this joke
that we do on stage at the cellar where
he said that,
uh,
all this ferguson stuff is
really starting to fuck with my,
um,
my personal life.
And he said,
no,
all these protests are really starting
to fuck with my personal life,
and those are the other day I'm
having sex with this black chick.
And she goes,
I can't breathe.
And he goes,
hey,
let's not bring politics into the bedroom.
Funny jokes,
but it was too soon and some
woman got up and yelled out,
that shit ain't funny.
And uh,
she started tweeting about it and I went
to her twitter page and just fucking
followed it like a hawk because
I thought it was fascinating.
And she was getting all these people.
There were social justice warrior
activists that were gonna.
They were gonna protest
at the comedy cellar.
We're going to show up at his clubs
were going to follow him around.
Yeah.
Hilarious.
Oh my God.
No.
Was with him at the cellar.
We were sitting at the table upstairs.
What did he say?
And he was talking,
it was before that.
He was talking about the espn one.
Oh,
that was another one.
He did?
Yeah,
about that.
Which we've read online or read on air.
He was hilarious.
And then he's going on about that.
And then two days later,
the other one,
and then I was just looking,
I thought I was looking up the espn one.
I was so confused.
I'm like,
wait,
this is a totally new one.
But it was so great.
He didn't stop.
He just put it out.
He just kept going.
Yeah,
he will.
He's doing what he's doing.
I mean,
todd,
I'm good buddies with Daniel Tosh and he,
uh,
he does a lot of stuff on the
show that people would be like,
that's racist or you're talking about
black people just because he's big and
black audiences love him.
Black Comedians love him.
And then other people come
up Mexicans and stuff.
Like,
why don't you ever mess with us?
Because they know it's a joke and it's
funny to laugh at yourself and it's his
style.
It's once people sort of
accept that that's your stuff.
You're an insult comedian,
right?
And you know,
the guys are,
you know,
that he's not a bad guy.
Like sorta like what people
want Jeff Ross to roast them.
If you ask Jeff Ross to Rosie,
you're asking him to start insulting
you mean that's what he does.
Everybody knows that
I worked with the wrinkles the summer.
Oh,
so great.
Where did you work with them?
I went to a,
in Montreal.
He was doing like when the
big gala shows staying,
doing two nights.
So he is doing stand
up just doing standup.
Wow.
And how much time did he do?
He did about probably like 45.
Oh yeah.
Whoa.
What was that like?
And then we get through a couple
of songs in and stuff like that.
He said was it was the greatest.
Yeah,
he sings this song at the end.
Was he saying about.
It's like,
this one's not thanks for the memories,
but it's something like that,
you know,
like see a little,
you know that a little,
like a little heartfelt
oh,
to try to warm you up after you
shit in your mouth for an hour.
Exactly,
exactly.
We all love each other.
And uh,
I,
you know,
I didn't get to meet dangerfield
and I Miss Carlin and I was like,
I just want to work with wrinkles at some
point and then it came up that I could
work with them at in Montreal and I
was supposed to go on vacation with my
family and I literally
sent my wife and kids.
I'm like,
I'm going meet up,
I'm going to be three days
late to our family vacation.
I'm going to go work with wrinkles.
I had to,
it was like,
this is,
yeah,
it's a comic that's an opportunity.
It's really hard to pass.
So I went up and uh,
and worked with him and
it was so great to see.
I mean,
his references are so date.
It's like,
look at the Puerto Rican guy who was
gonna come at me with a switchblade
switchblades what do you,
what do you,
what does the switch flip people,
friend of my Puerto Rican,
they're like,
what does a switchblade switch
blade will Puerto Rican.
It's like,
it used to be like a,
like almost like a negative term,
but it doesn't,
it's not anymore.
Right.
You know,
it's like you can't call
someone a Puerto Rican anymore,
like,
you know,
it's like calling someone
French from France.
What does that mean?
Are you from England?
I don't get it,
but his thing was he was.
So,
he's such a history of it.
Yeah.
Everybody knows this is what he
does and he does this kind of thing.
So was he working the
crowd the entire time?
Yeah,
it was kind of a,
it was kind of a mix.
Like he uh,
he brought people up.
He definitely,
I think when people on stage
for a couple of people,
two guys on stage,
wow.
Not Walking very well.
He doesn't walk very well know that
something's happened to his knee or
something and uh,
it's amazing.
You have all these show girls go up on
stage and they do this big dance in the
beginning of the show and they
do like the feather thing,
you know,
they all stand there with the feathers,
like a big scrim.
And then they wheeled him out and put
them up on a stool and then they all part
and there's Don rickles.
He just appeared to see
them walking and then he,
uh,
you know,
look at the black guy over there,
look at that,
look at the [inaudible] over there and
was doing the Hitler and crazy stuff.
It was great.
But he's just,
you know,
you know the guy so well,
you just know who he is.
So he,
you know,
it's not coming from hate
just as playful kind of guy.
And it was like,
I hope that there's somebody that's
going to be like that for our generation.
Should be somebody.
I think so.
I think like what you
were saying about Tosh,
what we were saying about Jeff Ross,
like once you know what they do,
if you just have to know what they do
and you know there's going to be building
complained,
but it doesn't matter.
They get,
they get ignored,
they get marginalized and you're
allowed to not like somebody managed.
People just don't like all
sorts of folks that I enjoy.
My whole objective those two days
was I just want to be shit on by him.
I was just lobbing stuff in like don.
Um,
so uh,
but we're working together two nights,
so like you know,
after that we're going to
know each other pretty well.
You think when we get back to la,
we're going to hang out,
don't push it.
Then I'm like waiting for them
with just totally that I liked.
Are you gonna Watch my act in height.
I really appreciate it.
If you watch my act,
I had my little busy
after the show.
I go back to his dressing room when
the cool thing was you would love it.
He just,
it's like old school show business
just walked into the building.
It's like,
you know,
even in Montreal it was kind of thing
is everyone's doing shows all week when
hit when it was his time for the show
guys in Tuxedos or walking around.
Security guys are hanging out old school
guys with like gel in their hair and
like show businesses happening.
This is,
the halls are cleared and
it's like this is just music,
classy music playing.
And it's like,
no,
we're doing a show.
Not Walking in and just gotten up on.
No,
this is a show.
So great.
So at the end I go to his dressing room,
he's in his dressing room in a,
in a silver,
like silk robe.
These little slippers.
This is post your slippers,
slippers,
gold stuff on the toes and he's
got all the makings for Martinis.
Got The ice,
has got the olives.
It's got the glass,
the shake,
but he just shoves it on his glass.
He just puts it all.
It doesn't even shake.
It just puts ice olives and vodka and
you sitting there drinking it and I go
back to see him.
He's like,
Tom,
come here.
He holds my holds.
My hand doesn't let go of my hand.
It's just the greatest.
And he was like,
Tom,
I watched your show tonight.
I've watched the whole thing.
Oh,
thank you don.
Thank you.
Have you considered a
career in grocery delivery?
You go around and deliver food
and you make people happy.
Throw in a joke once in a while to
keep yourself from killing yourself.
Like this is better
than the whole vacation.
I'm about to go on with my family.
So much better that.
Did you put pictures?
Did you take pictures?
And I got a couple shots.
That's huge.
Oh,
was just the best.
That's the best guy has
been added for forever.
Yeah.
I never met him.
I would love to meet that guy.
It's a good one.
I never got a chance to meet Dangerfield,
but I stood next to him a couple times.
He did?
Yeah.
He was doing some sets at the,
um,
at the laugh factory before he died,
like a and he performed up until
just a few years before he passed.
And in the nineties,
similar around the mid to late nineties,
he was doing sets occasionally he would
drop in the laugh factory and I was
really fortunate to be there
a couple times when he did.
Did he live out here?
Um,
I don't know.
I bet he probably lived a couple places.
It was pretty wealthy.
Um,
he,
um,
why don't you meet them though?
You were standing next to him.
I was young and stupid and I didn't.
I wasn't good enough.
I didn't feel like it was good
enough to introduce myself to him,
that I was next to him once when I was
an open mic or I just didn't feel like I
can introduce myself to them.
Just wasn't good enough.
Is it crazy to think there's some
kids standing next to you now?
Like I just can't.
I just can't kid say high.
Especially if you're a comic,
I'll talk to you know,
but there was a.
there's a couple moments
where you're like,
I saw Hicks live really two,
three,
three or four times,
probably three or four times
at least three times in Boston.
Three.
And that was a raw open miker.
Like I had been doing comedy maybe six
months and I got a chance to see Hicks a
bunch of times.
She has time.
It was awesome.
How good was he?
He was amazing,
man.
It's amazing.
Yeah,
it just like the late eighties.
He was probably in his prime.
He died in [inaudible] 93 or 94.
He died.
So I saw him when he was hopping.
I mean,
it was just,
he was on fire,
man.
He was so good.
I remember seeing him and I never saw
them live in some caroline's comedy hour
and just seeing how he was just
like at the edge of the stage,
cigarette in his hand is thinking
some guy's face like I was like,
what the hell.
This has been interesting to see how he
evolved and grew because he was still
young,
you know,
he was like 32 or something like that.
When he died,
he would have gotten a lot better.
It makes you seem so much older.
Well,
it makes you seem so
much more legendary to.
Yeah.
That's the other thing.
When someone dies,
like everything that they did become
so much more important than when it.
If they'd stayed alive.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Like if Elvis was still alive today.
Oh
yeah.
You just wrap it up.
Yeah.
Right.
I mean like John Lennon and there's
so much more valued by most people.
Then Paul Mccartney.
Yeah.
You know,
because Paul is showing up,
it would award shows and he's like,
hi,
I'm still alive and we
get it when you're dead.
We're gonna fucking love you dude.
Completely.
I saw dangerfield when I was working,
actually,
before I was ever a comic.
I got a chance to see I.
I worked at a concert place.
Oh yeah.
And I was backstage because there was a
security guard and I was working in this
backstage area where I got
to see dangerfield walking
around behind the stage
with his bathrobe on his slippers
and that's where he was performing.
He would perform in a
bathrobe in the bathroom.
He'd gone totally naked,
which throw a bathrobe on and just go on.
Yup,
Yup.
He went through a period of time.
That's how he was performing.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
When I saw them at the laugh factory,
he was fully dressed,
but he was doing this
place called great woods.
It's a concert place in Mansfield,
Massachusetts.
And this was the height of his popularity.
This was like back to school during
those days because this is like the
eighties,
I want to say like 86 or something
like before I did comedy,
that was probably 19,
so it must've been about 86 and uh,
he was just walking
around with a bathrobe on.
It would show shuffle
on stage with slippers.
I've got no respect that respect at all.
My wife will tell you and
you're just carrying the drink.
I don't remember.
It was carrying a drink.
I just remember,
look at this bad motherfucker
wearing a bathrobe.
It's crazy and everybody wanted to talk
about the fact that it had nothing on
under the bathroom.
The bathroom.
He's totally naked.
I saw his balls,
like he would just walk around.
Is that him?
Yeah,
there's that,
that there's a lot of photos of him where
you could actually see as Dick because
he's a sitting weird and
his dick hanging out.
Yeah,
he gave us Zeros.
That's like,
you know,
it's so weird to bring
up his name and his.
Because the context is we're
never like cosby went through.
He just come out in like sweatpants
and a thing and with socks.
Just socks.
Really?
Yeah.
Just come out with like birkenstocks
and take them off and just just.
Yeah,
well he wears everything
else was in crowd.
Were they a,
a sweatshirt on it says hello
friends or hello friend.
Really?
That's what he wears
when he goes on stage.
Now he's got this sweatshirt on.
It's just hello friend.
Yeah,
I guess you just do it so long.
You just like,
I guess,
right?
I mean the balls of that
guy to still do shows.
This is going down.
I now.
Do you think it goes online?
No,
no.
I think he had people that.
Right?
Because remember when he put up that meme,
they were like,
yeah,
blew up in his face.
See,
I have my own theories about that meme,
man.
I think that somebody who works for him,
he knew what the fuck was going to happen.
Oh yeah.
That's my,
my feeling.
One hundred percent.
And they just did it to get them.
Yeah.
I think that anybody who works in tech,
anybody who designed to websites,
you're savvy,
Internet savvy,
and if you're one of those
internet savvy people,
he know what the fuck is gonna happen.
If you say me,
me take a picture of him.
Yeah.
Hat on,
you know,
just let them rape jokes fly,
you know?
Do you.
Do you believe in any of this stuff?
Like the illuminaries hello friend,
Hollywood illuminati.
Uh,
like my uber driver was completely.
He thought for sure that like,
oh no,
Hollywood once some out now,
like he did something,
he fucked piss somebody off and they're
going after him and he had like this
whole theory and I'm like,
that's enough.
You know what I mean?
It can go away.
What
the key is an old heater.
That sentence is my uber driver
who's not making the
best fucking decisions.
Picking up random
strangers based on an APP.
Get in my car,
man.
Let me tell you what I think
about Hollywood and the
elite or what do you do in
that situation?
Just kind of agree with them to make
the conversation to get a free ride.
That's what you do.
Yeah.
He just had this whole
theory and he connected with
other celebrities that were,
he thinks like Hollywood's
just done with them.
So they throw him under the bus.
He said,
Charlie Sheen,
oh,
come on,
Charlie Sheen was on tv
talking about smoking rocks.
And then from then he went to get a deal
with fx that netted him somewhere in
the neighborhood of $500,000,000.
The same amount of money.
I mean,
I don't really got him.
How much did he make off that fx thing?
It was some insane amount of syndication.
It was 100 episodes.
More than $100,000,000 he made
off of that stupid fx thing.
And it's a terrible show.
Anger management is a Goddamn.
No one even knows it's on together by
monkeys with head injuries.
It's awful.
I mean,
it's so bad.
You watched the punchlines like what?
$200,
million dollar Charlie Sheen experiment.
God,
come on.
Well,
they were riding on the waves of
him leaving two and a half men what?
Look,
what were the other two and a half men.
Some fucking executives
that want to be seen.
Look at me.
I'm a big shot.
I'm like to do a blow and get hookers,
right?
Charlie?
What are we going to make?
How about a fortune?
Meanwhile,
you guys fucked up the TV business.
He'd dumb asses.
They did.
They tried to do that deal with a bunch
of other shows to try to do it with
George Lopez and it fizzled out.
Right?
Well,
they.
What they did is if you get past
a certain amount of episodes,
they automatically pick it up for 100.
Set it at 10.
Yeah.
If you get past 10,
right,
they automatically pick
it up for the back.
90.
Yes.
Insane.
But some dummy agree to that based on the
hype behind Charlie Sheen and the fact
that he was doing live
shows with no material.
Hey,
I forgot about the live show.
How could you put on.
One of them was he was a bastard.
That's not.
But then our boy russell saved it.
Russell Peters started doing shows with
them and saved it because Russell's
awesome comedian and started interviewing
Charlie and being funny while he was
interviewing them.
So Russell would crack some jokes,
asked some questions,
crack some more jokes,
and everybody was entertained by it.
And then Charlie could tell his crazy
hooker stories in context of like a,
uh,
like a show Biz set your panel.
Yeah.
Russell knows how to do theater,
right.
He knows how to entertain these people.
He's acutely aware that all
these folks are watching.
Whereas Charlie was just like,
I'm just going to go out
there and be Charlie Sheen and
give us our money.
He's like,
already got your money.
Remember that?
Those were awful devastating.
I mean he,
he and he was in a panic after that and
that's when they brought in comics and
started bringing comics
on the road with them.
And uh,
yeah,
but that was riding the wave of that.
They did this anger
management thing and you know,
the first couple episodes
probably weren't so bad,
but it's fucking terrible.
Yeah.
So take that aluminum 100 episodes
and it's not even their fault.
They're running 102 a week.
Yeah.
So how,
how,
how much time did they put
into these fucking jokes?
You can have almost none.
Almost no time.
There's hardly any time.
If you do one a week.
Yeah.
It's fucking hard.
Making a sitcom is fucking hard.
I've done it.
I did it for five years.
It is not easy.
It becomes easier once things get jealous.
But even then,
man,
writers fucking hit blocks.
They don't know what you mean.
There was days like we were in news radio,
like season four,
there was days where the
scriptures didn't fucking work.
These grinding,
these writers had busted their ass and
banged against the keyboards and they
just couldn't find a way to make this
scene work and they have what they've
abandoned a whole scenes and putting
on new ones and rewrite things the next
day.
Were you involved in writing
at all at that point?
Not Writing,
but I wrote a lot of the jokes that I
sat on the show I did ad Lib done on what
we do is onset the way the
way work with Newsradio.
Paul Simms,
who is a creative genius,
so really,
really smart guy,
but also he had a really healthy ego,
like it didn't have to be
his words that were read,
so he would write things.
And then Dave Foley was really like an
uncredited producer of that show is dave
rewrote entire scenes.
He rewrote jokes,
wrote jokes for me and for Vicky Lewis
and for Andy different everybody.
He rewrote stuff.
And then would present this new
version of it and dave was like really
respectful.
It's like we have this idea,
we'd like to see it.
And Paul was like,
yeah,
let's see what you got.
And then Paul would be like,
I like yours better,
let's go with that.
That's great.
And so like literally
40 percent of that show,
maybe even more was adlibbed set by by
either fully or Andy ad libbed a lot of
stuff.
I ad libbed a lot of stuff
we wrote for each other now.
Like sometimes you know,
you'd see Andy doing
something and I would go,
why don't you say this?
And be like,
Oh yes,
or no,
or Vicky or whoever.
It's like that sort of environment
where you can all contribute.
To me,
it just makes it better show,
but it's not always that you get a cast
that can do that and think about that.
Just those names that you're using.
Just this great.
Everyone's a killer.
And that's how difficult it
is to just pull up a show.
Use having all those killer,
all that talent.
Phil Hartman,
Stephen Root,
and one of the few that didn't run,
he didn't ad Lib anything.
Stephen Root would get
the script and he would.
He was a character like
if you talked to him,
will you see him on Newsradio?
You assume that he's that guy.
He's nothing like that guy.
He's the sweetest guy ever.
He's like,
he's so nice and normal
when you meet them,
but you know,
he'd had this.
Jimmy James Character was a
character that he developed.
He was the him and Phil Hartman
with the ones who were like.
They were like characters.
Yeah,
yeah.
They had developed the character.
Now imagine doing two of those a week.
Yeah,
it's impossible.
I don't know how the
fuck anybody would do it.
Right.
Not only that,
but doing two of them a week without Dave
Foley and without Paul Simms and maybe
the people that are writing
that show were good.
I don't know.
I don't know,
but also there's no fucking incentive.
When you got 90 episodes picked up.
It's like,
let's just smell this in go,
yeah,
we're stuck here.
It's,
you've got the GIG already.
Gigs not going to go away right now.
It's hard to pull those
things off the air.
Oh man,
that is rough.
Illuminati,
Illuminati.
Is that organized?
I don't think.
I don't even know what the Illuminati is.
I just consider it like Hollywood is
with this uber driver was talking about.
People always want to think that
when it doesn't work out for them.
That's the thing about Hollywood.
They all want to think that there's
some sort of grand conspiracy,
a hundred percent,
but you know,
I think that with A.
Whenever you talk to like you know,
I'm around comedians all the time,
so depending on who you're talking to,
they'll say,
well they don't want.
They're not,
they're not looking for white guys.
And then you talk to your other buddies
like they're not looking for black guys
because he's black and
whether or not Asians,
there's only one Asian.
You can gather everybody wherever you are,
you think they don't want,
but if you can create something and
that something is popular and that's
something is sellable and then people
are buying it and everybody loves it,
that's one of the beautiful things about
being a comic is that you can prove it
on your own.
If you develop a following and you go
on stage and you start killing it on the
road and everybody wants to come see you,
they want to do a show with Tom,
papa,
Tom,
what are we going to do?
How do we get a po?
How do we get a piece of this money and
time trying to figure out how to profit
off of what you're doing?
Right,
exactly.
You know this idea that there's
some sort of a grand conspiracy.
Know what you're selling sucks,
right?
That's what you're selling.
You're selling is nothing.
Yeah.
Right.
Exactly,
and no one's interested.
That's conspiracy.
Conspiracy.
People are conspiring to only
put things that they like on TV.
Sorry.
You don't fit into that plane.
Oh,
Bill Cosby is a part
of a grand conspiracy.
That's hilarious.
They ties all these different women
and they got them to say the exact same
thing.
And Randy Quaid,
did you see that video
ratings crazy as fuck.
Yeah,
quaid crazy as fuck.
What happened?
He released a new video today
where he knew him really well.
I don't know if it's the same one.
I just saw the crazy white beard and he
puts a mask on his girlfriend simulates.
So these fucking bad acting really nice.
She's gone nuts.
He went crazy.
He went crazy a couple of years ago,
owed a lot of money and there was
like a house that he was living in.
They kicked him out and he
was running from hotels,
seed ranch.
Real expensive place.
Beautiful place,
right?
You can crank up a real big bill and a
couple of days and he stayed for six days
and then split.
Didn't pay it.
He did that a couple of places.
Oh man,
it got weird.
Oh,
it's.
You know,
when people get old,
some people,
they have a tendency for centricity and
then as they get old that morphs into
full blown.
Crazy.
Right.
You know,
it's like you got a little bit of a
cold and then next thing you got aids.
What's really weird is that his girlfriend
is out of your control is his wife is
on the on board though,
so it almost seems like maybe they're
just drug addicts together instead of
being a crazy thing because
the fact that she's not like,
my husband's going crazy.
They might just be parts of both.
Get on the same page with that.
That's a good point.
Yeah.
It might be messed up.
They're not using their
drugs like they don't put.
No,
they're actors just don't do drugs,
man.
Gene in this conspiracy the fuck.
I've
been interviewed by the ABC talking
about doing rocks and rocks.
You remember that?
Yeah.
That's how I roll.
Right,
exactly.
Get off.
Yeah.
I know a couple of rows that have signed
the papers where they're not allowed to
talk about the stuff that
happened with Charlie Sheen.
He makes them sign confident,
confident that she.
You give them money or
just hanging out with them.
Shit.
Loads of money.
Like really retarded amounts
of money for doing nothing.
Girls just to come hang out.
It is now,
let's just say that he's a big fan of
prostitutes and I think when you've got
the kind of money that that guy's got,
I mean,
he's been on several big time series a
bunch of movies probably worth close to a
billion dollars at this point.
Right?
So when you've got that,
putting aside 100 grand
for some little Greta,
nothing.
Listen,
senior retail,
we had some strange times.
A lot of people wouldn't understand
what went on between you and me and the
glass table.
You and I love it,
but they wouldn't understand.
He's got a transmission issue and you
need to get your tires changed and I'm
willing to do that for you.
I'll actually put a little bit
of sugar in your bank account.
Just sign this.
Put a little sugar in your bank account.
Yeah.
I ran into this gal once at the
comedy store back in the day,
uh,
with her new boyfriend that was one of
the playboy bunnies that lived on the,
at the house.
And she was apparently going
to write some tell all,
but I don't know if she
ever wind up doing it.
But you know,
those,
those stories where people have that
sort of a situation where you know,
you're getting paid by some guy and
there's some money being exchanged.
Semi prostitutional type situation.
Just get weird.
You know,
you're dealing with some uber wealthy cat.
Oh Man.
You know,
fucked up.
And like some crazy king.
Yeah.
Well he was like,
well if you have to.
It's kind of like a crazy king.
It's weird.
Harem of young gals and
walking around in his robe.
I think another role.
Another guy,
he's got a smoking jacket though.
It's got to get robes,
robes,
eat robes.
That's.
We should do a whole show in robes.
You down.
I'm that lady.
That lady is making us
those astronauts shirts.
I can't wait.
What are those?
Do you remember that?
There was a scientist that got in trouble.
They landed on a comet.
They landed a robot on a comment
and the guy who was celebrating it,
he wore a shirt that his friend designed.
It was his friend who's
into like rockabilly sort of
pin up girl type stuff and
she,
she that,
that picture right there,
that,
that was like an homage to his friend
because his friend made him that shirt and
that's what she does.
So he said,
I'll just wear.
I'll wear your shirt on TV and
then all these people got so mad.
Like,
look at this against women.
Roll up,
scroll up,
look at the,
the,
the actual title is,
I don't care if you landed
a space craft on a comment.
Your shirt is sexist and ostracizing
you fucking Tommy is so bad ass.
Awesome.
Not only that,
it's just sexy.
I mean if he was wearing a
shirt with a bunch of men,
masters of the universe on it,
the Tarzan with his long flowing locks,
swinging from anybody complained,
negative sell.
It could be on the back,
right?
If that girl,
if the girl interviewing
him for whatever reason,
if the roles were reversed,
if he was the interviewer and she was
the scientist and she had a shirt on like
a bowling shirt with a
bunch of like studly,
bodybuilder do dot,
it would be funny.
Right,
exactly.
Yeah.
Just have a good time.
Enjoy your lives.
Well this,
these are just pin up girls.
They're just girls in like swanky,
sort of like,
he invented that stuff.
Fucking assholes.
No one likes to have fun anymore.
Let's have a good time.
Who are you?
That's so upsetting to you?
What's wrong with you?
It's just fucking shirt.
He'll be one thing.
It was a bunch of chicks getting fucking
double penetrated was like a bunch of
chicks getting just,
you know what a airtight is.
Yeah.
I uh,
had a friend and
his friend was dating a porn star
and he was cool with it for awhile.
It was like,
oh,
it's okay.
You know what?
She brings home girls and all
this different jazz and uh,
you know,
uh,
what do you think about,
oh,
it's just sex.
And then one day he got ahold of her
contract and the contract said air tight.
It was like in the
contract and he was like,
what's airtight?
She's like a Dick and every hole.
He's like,
I'm out.
Done sober on track.
This is not my special lady.
This is not my specialty.
He just.
That was,
that was the breaking point.
I can't explain that one to my mom.
It's just sitting in
there going air air tight.
And that was it.
I'm sorry.
What?
What does that mean?
Like he was cool.
He was cool with her,
with two guys.
but three was it.
Three was where he just about air tight.
It's like that's a sure sign this
too much porn being made right.
That a plug.
Every hole has it been done?
No plug and plug it up.
We're innovators.
Get that little guy.
We got two years to fill
a lawyer.
Drafting that contract to squirt and
lube and your ear and just grabbing a top
and a bottom and just the
two midgets or making out.
So they're gay.
If they're making out with each other,
whether they skull fucker ears and
another guy's fucking her mouth,
put that on a shirt.
It's probably been done.
We probably were wrong.
I don't think you can think up anything
that hasn't probably at this point,
right?
It's probably Asian man.
What?
What year was the first
asked to mouth done?
I mean that had to be
in the two thousands.
Right.
That didn't exist.
If you go back to the glory days
of like a Ginger Lynn and Ron,
Jeremy and Peter North,
there was no to mouth.
They didn't
have to.
It was just people having sex fashion.
Good time.
Like when Don rickles does that show,
he's got a silver robot and slip as that
show business we didn't have to do what
you do have to do as to mouth are tighter
in this fucking midget fucking your
ear and nonsense gimmicks.
It's what you rely on
when you got no talent.
It's like boogie nights.
I don't do video.
I make film.
Do Video.
Do they even make films anymore with film?
They don't use film anymore,
right?
Some do.
Do they hardly do for movies,
but you could bring.
There's some directors that only want
to shoot film because they don't believe
in the whole digital Tarantino.
Right.
He's a wild man.
Think documentaries.
A lot of documentaries maybe still be
on film photographers to believe in
photography like that.
It has to like digital photography,
like some something's missing,
right?
Nobody else sees.
It's like when people are like,
no,
you've got to use this
gold cable for your system.
It's gonna,
you know,
you can use an instagram filter to
achieve all that you fuck for free.
Yeah.
I don't think the new star wars movie,
they're not using like CGI this time
around or they're using like old school
like puppets and like
how they used to do it.
It's going to be pretty cool.
So there was definitely an overload
of CGI where you're just like,
am I if I'm watching a
video game at this point?
Yeah.
The Guy who directed my last comedy
special in wanting to do it in black and
white,
Steven Spielberg will bird
did his in black and white,
but I think he actually filmed it.
I don't know,
maybe he didn't,
but I.
This was before that,
before birth or even before I even knew
bill doing isn't black and white and I
go,
but it's already in color.
Like why would they do that?
Like what?
Why not just draw it,
take all the frames and
drop everything I'm doing.
Just do your best colorize it.
Have an option to make it black and white
by turning it on and off on your TV.
You can make any special black
and white if you can do that.
Right?
But if you fuck with the
contrast in the color color,
God,
it's just so weird.
This desire for the archaic to go back
to the old old timey camera and I'm going
to put the fucking needle on the
turntable that you got me.
Like it's still not working right?
Do we ever do anything about that?
Oh really?
What's wrong with it?
Jamie?
Get on the ball.
So,
so yeah,
that's the problem.
Wasn't working.
I got my daughter a
turntable and it didn't work.
We have to bring it back.
Then the other thing that starts skipping,
it's like,
yeah,
this is why we stopped
seeing this kind of shitty.
It's cool though.
It's undeniable that the
sound is a little different.
It's undeniable.
Well,
apparently there's a new walkman
that's expensive as fuck.
It's a new Sony Walkman
and it's an MP three recorder that is
supposed to have the most incredible
premium sound and Sony just released
this at the latest video show,
the consumer electronics
show in Vegas in Vegas,
and it's a big gamble because it's
like more than a thousand bucks.
Are you serious?
Yeah.
Here,
I'll pull it up and we'll try this little
while Neil Young's book or read about
Neil Young's book.
He has this.
Sony wants you to buy a 1000,
$200.
MP three player.
Okay.
What's that sound?
Hold on.
Now you're hearing a sound stopped.
Was on this cable.
Oh,
the Kayla.
Does that chronic as we're
talking about better sound?
Uh,
yeah.
Ironic.
Last one.
Sone.
Finally unveil.
New Walkman MP.
Three player.
Which many have been
expected for some time.
People first got to look at device at ces.
Two thousand 15 was asleep design or
excellent ergonomics that caught people's
eyes.
It was the price tag.
The zx priced at just under 1000,
$200 for.
That's more than a phone which
already has an MP three player.
Yeah.
Hm.
Ha.
Why?
Because it sounds so great
as the audio files choice,
a new focus of the music and,
and we'll see.
I think that this kind of,
this kind of technology
will exist in phones soon.
Right?
That's the thing.
But to buy it as a handheld outside,
I don't have a fucking
thing outside of my phone.
Okay.
I have one for phone.
My phone has a 128 fucking gigabytes.
There's plenty of God damn songs in
this thing and I'm not buying something
else.
No.
And if I took a MP three file that was
say record at 1:28 kilobits per second or
whatever,
or you know,
twice that played both of them.
I really doubt most of us would even
care or hear the difference in it at all.
Well,
you know,
what does matter though is really good.
Headphones.
Yeah.
Really good.
Headphones matter,
my kids can play like their phones,
the coldplay song just in that speaker
and just leave it and it's Gacaca Gacaca
and they love it and it
really drives me crazy.
I just came here.
That lame quality.
It just drives me nuts.
I have these earbuds from.
Sure.
Oh yeah.
And they have like steel braided cables
that are covered with plastic or they're
very expensive and I was like,
all right,
let me just,
just for a goof by these things
and see if it makes a difference.
It makes a big fucking.
It does,
yeah.
They have like drivers inside the ears,
like the little,
but they feel weird phone.
Yeah,
plug it into my phone.
It's fucking fantastic.
And they're like blown
away like the regular.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
It's quite a bit quieter.
It's quite a bit better,
you know,
is it.
I don't remember how much it
costs a lot of money though,
but yeah.
Is it like a thousand dollars better?
I don't know.
Right.
It's interesting that driver thing,
because beats when they were still
together with Dr Dre and beats,
you know,
they used their own special driver.
A lot of people complain
that it was really basic
and too,
too much base now that they broke up.
I just got a new pair and
it's completely different.
It's like it doesn't even seem like
the same headphones even though it was
specific.
Almost exactly the same headphones I used
to have the same but it doesn't sound
the same reading and
they're bluetooth now.
So you just have these awesome headphones.
You can answer calls on them.
I mean it's great.
It's so.
And you guys are tech savvy.
He's a Lebron,
you know,
he's doing like the beats,
wireless,
things like that working out.
So if you're running though,
that means you're like
I run with a shuffle,
you know,
connected.
But that's not bluetooth.
Now you can't do it with a shuffle,
but you mean you can.
I'm running through the streets,
but the IPOD shuffle,
right?
Those little tiny ones with
the clip on those dope.
Just put them right on
your waistband and go,
well,
you can't use the wireless now for that.
See what you need is a fucking
phone and a fanny pack.
Everyone's scared of Goddamn fanny packs.
It's the way to go.
You slipped out,
sucker right in there,
clip it down and go run
and do whatever they have.
You're running with your phone?
Yeah,
I run with my phone.
That makes me nervous.
I don't really run though.
They had to use for
like running type stuff.
I do everything on a treadmill or on a.
not even a treadmill.
Usually elliptical machine.
You're not running through
the streets like a maniac.
I do plenty of pounding with
my joint hitting things.
I don't like to do extra
pounding for a budget.
I think I've already taken chances
with my joints from kickboxing.
Fuck with it.
With all that other stuff.
Yeah.
I just stopped getting nervous
up running with my phone.
They have those cases.
I have one that your phone goes in and
it just goes on your own and those are
good and you don't even feel
like you have it on there.
Oh really?
Do you have the.
You don't have the plus though.
You have the six.
I went back down to the six.
You have a blessed.
Do you like it?
I love it.
I feel like I got the six and I feel
like I should have gotten a bigger.
What's better?
The battery life is tremendous.
It's so great.
The battery's good for
like couple of days.
It's really good.
You know,
like I can listen to music.
I believe I bring it to when I do shows,
I have a bluetooth hooked
up to this little speaker.
I set the speaker up in the green room.
I play music with it
and then I get onstage.
I record all my sets with it
and I go to shows with that,
play in the music,
all that and pictures.
No braylee,
no problems.
The battery does go on.
The sixth one.
You're listening to the last supper.
Watching stuff goes.
I mean the six is essentially
the same batteries.
A five,
the five s it's the same battery.
It is this.
Yeah.
This basically the same battery
life but a larger screen.
So it sort of counters.
It might be a slightly larger battery,
but a larger screen.
I always buy the wrong stuff to do.
You could
get a new one,
give it away,
give it to somebody,
to somebody.
Give it to your kid.
Yeah.
You know,
I guess
first world problem.
I always find things twice.
I'm never like think things through.
I had to make the right purpose.
I have a podcast phone for the studio
that's a Samsung Galaxy s five and there's
parts of that that I liked
better than the iphone.
A little bit smaller.
It's five inches instead of a.
is this just because you're
friends with Newell Brands?
Like five point five now?
I don't want to say anything that
gets Neal Brennan in trouble,
but he might not always
use the phone all the time.
I don't know what you're talking about.
What I like about this,
the um,
the Samsung is this
little bad boy right here.
This thing would it clips in place
before you can drop it in the toilet.
It's fucking waterproof.
It water resistant,
but the fucking thing and
go under water and be fine.
Whereas if this bitch goes underwater,
it's a dead man.
There's nothing scarier than like having
a glass of water next to your phone on
the counter and it's got a
heartbeat detector right there.
You put your finger over there and it
shows you your heartbeat to see if you're
in love.
Yes,
it's very important.
It's a mood ring,
which you can do with
apps and now the Apps,
the way you put your finger over the,
it actually measures.
They have an app on the
iphone where it measures the,
uses the flash from the camera and
it pulses on your finger and actually
measures the,
uh,
the heartbeats from reading with
the Camera Lens and reading your,
your,
the,
the light on your finger.
That's amazing.
Easy,
right?
He's a great world.
We live in.
What I like about this though,
there's two things that I
like about the Samsung first,
the big one is you could take the
fucking battery out and put a new one in.
So if your battery runs
dry extra in your bank,
you put a separate battery pack and
you have a full charge instantly.
Then also I like,
you can add memory,
you could stick a little memory card
in there and you get an extra 128 gigs.
Yeah.
But you don't,
you don't seem as cool.
Were you trying to impress Tom Pop?
I don't know everybody I think.
Well we,
there's no perfect phone
is what I'm saying.
There's parts of this that I love
seeing the two phone numbers.
Yes.
This is the uh,
the studio phone.
Gotcha.
Yeah.
This is,
this is better.
yeah.
This is a better operating system.
The iphone operating
system is clearly better.
Right.
And the iphone camera
is a little better too,
but that's pretty God damn good.
I mean the difference between the galaxy
operating system and the iphone and the
camera and the camera.
And this is.
So you're kind of splitting hairs.
Yeah.
It feels the same.
Brian Disagree.
Have you fucked with the SRO?
Apple if you fucked
with the galaxy s five.
I know,
but I've heard a lot of
complaints about the Svi,
especially with the a thumbprint sensors
sensor is dog shit.
I do love.
I do love that.
About it's great on the iphone.
It's dog shit.
Oh really?
Yeah,
like I'll show you.
Watch.
I have to do it like four times.
Shit.
Watch.
Here we go.
Let's look.
It says swipe the entire pad.
Why?
You have to tell me that.
Okay,
I'll swipe it.
Oh No,
match.
You fucking cunt.
No match again.
You fuckhead.
Let's see Warren.
Time.
Three times.
It's my thumb.
I only have one of them.
You fuck.
I've been five.
Unsuccessful attempts
to unlock your device.
Try again in 30 seconds.
That's it.
I'm out.
You couldn't go through that.
I really couldn't.
Fucking son of a bitch.
You're getting chased down an alley
trying to call nine slash 11 while you're
doing this crap or you know.
The best thing is just go on a road trip.
Have both phones.
Try to use that on the way to somewhere
and try to use the iphone on the way
back.
You'll know what I'm talking about.
This crap.
Case closed counselor.
One second.
Let's see,
one second.
Let's see if I can do it faster.
Is sent me anything recognized.
Oh,
you recognize me?
You love me.
That's so cute.
We like it.
Joe.
It's disgusting.
Now,
did you.
What's up?
Did you do both?
Thumbs.
Are you using like the wrong thumb?
Like you only did one
film and not the others.
Oh Man.
No,
no.
I mean,
I mean I,
yeah,
I use one thumb.
I only use one thumb on
this fucking piece of shit.
I opened my laptop at home
and it,
there's my wifi and then there's the
printer Wifi and it just goes to the
printer Wifi.
I opened it up and I go to and
it's just that having to go
change it from the printer
to the thing every time.
Just forget that me,
I might move.
You should kill someone.
I literally physically
with the table like Oh,
anger.
But I mean the idea of even having a
fingerprint sensor on your phone was so
sexy.
Just a little while ago.
They came out with that.
With the.
Was this the first one?
I had the fingerprint sensor
with the iphone or the last five?
Five.
Like the upgraded five?
Yeah.
I'd love the fingerprint sensor.
It is general that cops can force
you to use the fingerprint sensor,
but they can't force you to enter in your,
um,
your code.
Wow.
So have you ever get addressed,
arrested,
delete all of your fingerprints?
I have a great tip.
I just found out that it's really scary.
Is that turn off?
Turn off this thing,
you know,
like if you have your phone
up and you go up like that,
you can have like that quick menu shit.
Like you lose your phone,
somebody picks it up,
they put it in airplane mode so you
can't find your phone and they steal your
phone.
So there was no way for the
find your phone app to find you.
So you need to turn off
this swipe up Mineo uh,
because that's what they do.
Like if you leave a phone in a taxi,
the taxi guy goes up.
No,
now he knows.
Now that you're sharing this
information with the terrorists.
Jesus Christ.
Brian.
Brian,
that does make sense though.
They can't use the phone,
your phone because people have
gotten their asses kicked from that.
Find your phone,
will you,
you know someone stole your phone.
You Ding Dong.
Excuse me.
You have my phone.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I got to find your phone APP.
You fuckhead they could
only find the address.
They can't find like what room it's in.
You have to tear someone's Goddamn House.
Go through the whole hotel.
How accurate is it?
It's not like one of those.
No,
it's pretty on homing devices.
How motivated you phone?
Like what if it's an
apartment building in.
It's pretty accurate
Joe,
because I own my house.
I can see exactly what room I'm in.
If I look at myself,
it does it.
What does it show you?
It shows me the outline of my house in
Google maps and then it shows me what
room I'm in this room.
Your phone,
isn't it?
Yeah,
I'll use that.
Like if I can't find my phone,
I'll go on my laptop and make it play
a sound and I'll find my phone like,
you know,
underneath the couch
or something like that.
That's incredible.
So I could play a sound even if it's off.
Right.
Even if the sound the ringer's off.
Yeah.
There's also another app
I recommend called secret,
which is another one that I put on all
my phones and my laptops and stuff and
what it is.
It's a program that's always running
that does the same kind of thing,
but you could also turn on
your Webcam and take photos.
So if somebody stole your laptop,
they won't even know that you're
just sitting at filming them,
getting their gps,
get every single key type that they type
in or your girlfriend can put that shit
on your phone and catch,
you know,
it always comes back to bite Ya.
My.
I did the find your phone.
It's like my friends or something to see
where my daughter was and it's not that
accurate.
It's always like it said she was in a
black neighborhood and that's just not.
It can't be.
Right.
That's just bad technology.
I made no sense.
Tell me,
you were at school,
you were at school.
It's way more accurate if you're
connected to a wifi network.
Like if she's not connected to a wifi
network and it has to try to guess where
it's where it is,
but it doesn't work on airplane mode.
Huh?
That's weak.
Yeah.
They need to change that
or they need to make it.
So your thumbprint.
If it's locked that menu.
I love that swiping up thing.
They'll use the flashlight.
I use the flashlight all the time.
There's no way I'm turning
off that up swipe thing.
Yeah.
That's why it bumped things.
Pretty Dope.
I just wonder if you could turn it off.
You know from the lock screen,
like if it's on a lock screen,
I like to use a camera from that or just
alarm.
Oh,
there's things I can't do two steps.
God dammit can't handle that.
It's very busy.
You have a little day.
Take a little bit about.
It's just things are constantly improving.
They're constantly innovating
and adding to them.
And that sound thing that
you see on that walk,
man.
You'd be a silly person to buy
that stupid $1,200 dollar walkman.
Oh yeah.
Because that's going to
be in your phone soon.
That sort of.
I know they're working on that.
They're working on improvements or I've
read something about the digital cell
phones working on improvements of sound
quality in anticipation of these types
of devices.
You know what I want them to do?
Do you use apple pay?
Do you use that brain wave?
The phone.
He's waving the phone and it pays.
I want them to fix the
a toll system at lax.
You ever get in the car after a
Gig or whatever and then you like,
there's that line and nobody has the
thing and find the card and it just takes
me to get out of there.
You can't tell me there's not going to
be an APP and a waving of the phones.
It's going to solve this problem.
We should be out of here immediately.
I remember when the fast pass in
New York pass through and
you could just drive through.
You didn't have to pay the tolls.
Amazing.
So excited.
You just had to drive.
The main light went on.
You went right through.
It saves so much fucking
time and traffic's so much
time because traffic in New
York on toll booths used to be insanity.
No,
you wanted to fucking eat his shotgun.
Have you ever rented a car in New York
and realized you didn't have the fastest
time through anyway written that bill?
That was always cool.
I'm not staying in that.
Like you bill me.
She always did the pimp mood.
Like he would have a
rental car and he was like,
what?
PTO drive right by.
It was so cool.
I think that's so awesome.
I don't give a fuck man.
You get a bill in the mail.
You pay a shit.
I don't even pay my bills.
Somebody else pays Mongo.
I don't even feel it.
You have a business guy
trying to get one of those.
Is it great?
Oh,
I just met a guy yesterday.
Well my guys,
a good friend that I've
had for a long time.
You want to know the dude?
This guy knows he's worked
with other good friends.
That helps.
Um,
but it does make your
life that much better.
Oh,
most certainly does.
Well,
it's for everything too.
Like if you want to buy a house,
if you want to buy a car,
if you need take,
take care of your bills.
They took care of everything.
They give you an itemized monthly report
every week on your phone or every month
and finances and you don't have to worry.
You have to think about anything.
It's great.
We just downstairs a lot of time
involved in being a human being.
That takes away from work
that you could be doing.
The ache actually makes you more money.
Right?
So when people say,
oh,
but it's,
you're giving away x amount
of percent of your income.
Yeah,
but I'm making more money because I'm
thinking more and I'm doing more sit in
front of my fucking computer.
Paying bills for hours every night,
writing checks,
track,
keep track.
And remember balancing
a checkbook locked up.
Fuck John Ledger Ledger.
Yeah.
No,
I'm so.
I feel like so tapped out for time.
No,
I need a staff.
And,
and this,
this seems like good for a spot where
you're a comic and you have a family too.
And so there's a lot of stuff.
This.
I have too many things going on for that.
Yeah.
All right.
I'm going to do it.
I'm broke.
Well,
listen.
Well that has happened to,
you know,
there have been guys that
have been unscrupulous.
I remember there was a um,
there was an issue way back in the
day where there was an agent that was
stealing money from a bunch of,
like big name clients,
like Lenny Clarke got hit stolen hundreds
of thousands of dollars from him and
Jerry Seinfeld.
It was like,
really?
Yeah.
There was an agency that was going
on that was doing that for pe.
I forget.
I'll have to ask lenny
next time I see him.
Yeah.
But it was devastating for a lot of
these guys who'd lost just hundreds of
thousands of dollars.
Somebody just Dane Cook's brother.
Oh yeah.
That was bad.
That was really brutal.
In jail.
Yeah.
Imagine your brother is in jail for
robbing you and they have never recovered
millions of that money.
Well,
there was a lot that
was owed to the irs to.
There's a lot o to the irs,
but it's also missing.
One of his brothers stole money from him
and went on a drive across the country
and they don't know what the
fuck he did when he was driving.
He could've stopped at banks and got
security boxes under assumed names.
I mean,
I don't know how much is involved
in getting a security box at a bank,
but there might be shank.
It's very deep.
I mean there might be fucking coffee
cans somewhere under fence posts with a
million dollars rolled up in it.
I'm gonna find it.
I mean,
have you ever seen what a million dollars
looks like in a bag of $100 bills?
It's not as much as you would think it is.
You've seen it.
It's like a suitcase,
like a small bag do is
just dig a fucking hole.
You throw that shit in there.
We just got to be able to
triangulate it on a gps and oh shit.
Actually get there and there's an
apartment building where the spot was.
Whereas
20 years in the big house,
the big house,
that's an awful story.
What's fucked up because
it was his brother too,
and it was any found out
after his parents passed.
It was brutal.
He also,
I think it was a half brother,
which he should be really careful of
those little Fox brothers rather than
trying to pretend the brother.
What's the other half lives?
Yeah,
they have you fuck.
But um,
his brother apparently,
you know,
Dane was like,
I'm,
I'm going to start investing my money,
all those different things.
I talked to this guy and his brother,
like,
Nah,
don't do that.
Don't do that.
Look,
I got this.
I got the door.
I'm taking care of everything,
making plenty of money.
It's like,
well,
what do you mean I'm a bug?
So he started asking questions.
Well,
I want to get somebody to
just go over the finances,
got everything,
don't worry about it.
Don't worry.
I was like,
what?
And then he started getting like,
super nervous,
like,
what are you talking about?
And then he,
and then he started to
get it investigated.
And when you've got an investigator,
he realized his brother
just fucking dealing.
Oh,
they went to his house,
he had hundreds of thousands
of dollars in his bank.
Safe Rather.
Yeah.
After all that success,
he had work.
He had money that was in plastic
bags that was frozen in tomato sauce.
Like he had frozen it and
put it in the freezer,
stuffed in like these,
these plastic bags and
then put it in his freezer.
Like he was hiding money all over the.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
It was dark.
I had is crazy.
And it was his,
his own blood.
He trusted his brother.
He thought his brother
and hell never fuck me.
But you know,
I guess his brother was like,
fucking good as noodle this money.
Oh see you don't even know if you
stole from him.
Oh Man.
Yeah,
it's dark.
That is really dark.
All right.
Maybe I'll do my own billing.
Yeah,
I don't know man.
It's real tricky when you're trying
to save money like that and trying to.
Yeah,
but that's the thing.
I mean if I wouldn't
stop being on top of it,
you know what I mean?
We're all my savings.
You know what I mean?
Here to kind of monitor
that stuff all the time.
You should.
You most certainly show.
Yeah.
You know,
it's all,
it's all for the kids.
It's just all like,
it's all setting them up,
you know what I mean?
And he doesn't know anything.
Yeah.
So it's all like,
it's all just for the future small,
you know what I
mean?
That's crazy accounts where
someone could like mess with me.
Yeah.
I know people that don't
even have managers,
they just have an agent and they just do
everything through their agent and have
agents take care of everything.
I'm like,
but you know,
like,
well,
like I'm saving money.
I'm like,
yeah,
you are,
but you have to think
about more stuff that way.
Right.
That's the.
I know that's really,
that's.
It sucks up so much of your brain power
just to have to go and do that stuff.
Also,
I think that if you think too
much in the financial sense,
like how much am I making?
How much more can I make?
I can get this out of them.
Well,
I'm going to ask for that and
hopefully I'll get like less.
But you know,
all overshoot,
but if you,
if you have all that kind of
thinking going on in your head,
I think that's contrary
to creative thinking.
I think creative thinking
is like non selfish,
non aware.
Like when,
when I think like creatively I'm empty.
When I think it might sit
in front of my computer.
I'm not thinking about myself at all.
I'm thinking about the idea.
I'm not thinking,
hmm,
how much money can this idea make me?
You know?
Right,
exactly.
It's a.
that's back to the the weed thing.
Yes.
Because I really started feeling like
I'm uber responsible and I'm running this
company running this
comp Papa Incorporated,
pop incorporated,
doing the radio show,
doing the TV stuff,
doing the standup stuff,
doing all this,
managing all this stuff,
taken care of the family,
taking care of everybody,
all these human beings doing all this.
And I'm like,
I don't start smoking weed.
I'm going to literally turned into IBM.
Seriously.
I'm like,
I needed not all the time,
but I need to.
I'd like riding high.
I write my best stuff when I'm high
original stuff or punch up stuff both of.
I mean I write without it too.
There's a lot of times when I write I
just sit down and write and sometimes
those ideas are great jokes
or great ideas or great bits,
but yeah,
but there's stuff that
comes to me when I'm high,
when I'm like,
this is just a gift by the universe.
There's just something just
came into my head that I would,
I don't think I would've
come up with without the.
We now know it kicks up in these doors.
Yeah.
I mean that was like,
that's like a famous quote by Carl Sagan.
Carl Sagan had a famous quote about,
about what marijuana does to you.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
This is like a here.
I'll find it.
There's a famous quote.
I mean,
Carl Sagan was like,
uh Oh,
a known pothead.
I didn't love that.
Yeah.
I'm convinced that there are genuine
and valid levels of perception available
with cannabis and probably with other
drugs which are through the defects of our
society and our educational system
unavailable to us without such drugs.
Carl motherfucking Sagan.
Well,
smoking weed,
using the telescope lightened bitches.
Brain's on fire.
Billions and billions and
billions and billions of stars.
You like the new cosmos?
Yeah.
Love it.
It's great.
He's amazing and it's got into it.
Well,
he's another one.
Neil degrasse Tyson,
like in making that,
that show has taken so much shit from
creationists and from fucking people that
you should show the other side as well.
How about having a creation is
to bait you upon your program.
They wouldn't run it in Kansas,
right?
Yeah.
They literally,
the first week it was like,
oh,
they said it was just didn't
happen real in that second week.
It was like,
oh no,
this is not running.
It.
Is that true?
Is a station at Google?
Google.
It was like the premiere
of the Cosmos did not run.
And Kansas.
Yeah.
Is that true?
Yes.
God,
it is.
they didn't run the uh,
the premier episode and they were like,
they said like it was a problem with
something like the broadcast or something.
And then what does that false.
False.
Oh,
you fucking purveyor of bad information,
Tom.
Papa.
No,
I saw an interview where he is.
I saw her.
I saw it on.
What's his name?
No,
what's his name?
Talking about it.
Seth rogen.
Know the other stuff.
Seth Macfarlane dancing one.
Who's that?
Seth Macfarlane Mcfarland.
While he.
He's full of Shit.
He's probably high pending a bill.
It would force Fox television network.
It's too many words.
What's it say?
Because
that's about a law.
I'm not wrong.
All right,
thank you.
This is.
You have a cracked staff here.
Well,
he gets a lot of shit though.
For sure.
He gets a lot of shit from creationists,
man.
People that are upset with him because
he's illuminating people on the actual
facts and measured reality of
the Internet of the universe.
The universe rather.
George Carlin said that
he would smoke doing.
He would come up with his ideas straight
but then make it funnier and punch it
up.
Yeah,
I mean everybody's got their own method.
That's not a bad method because for me,
I like to write high as fuck.
Sometimes when I ride high as fuck,
like sometimes I'll get high as fuck
and I think I'm going to go into the
isolation tank and my computer just,
she goes,
come here man,
come here,
sit down,
just sit down and start
writing on the computer.
And I never make it into the tank.
Really?
Yeah,
just an idea comes.
Yeah.
And it just gets out of my head like
in these big bursts and I feel like.
Yeah.
And I feel like you gotta you
just gotTa capture those moments,
you know,
you gotta figure.
That's why I think it's very important
for comics to be able to type.
Well there's a lot of comics can't they
pack and poke and you miss out on them
ideas because you can't write.
Can't grab them out of
the air quicker now.
Yeah.
Do you ever write longhand?
No,
I mean I do,
but when I write like
it's like all this shit,
like during shows and stuff or have an
idea that I don't want to forget their
most of what it is.
It's just like really
quick cliff notes or um,
when I have a,
my notebook that I use for shows,
I just write the same things
down over and over again.
Like if you look at my notebook,
I'll look like a crazy person because I'm,
I'm just trying to remember the order
and make sure that I get the key punch
lines,
especially on new stuff.
It's like the shining page
after page of the same stuff.
It's weird to use notes on your iphone.
Yes.
You do that?
What is it called?
Mine's called Bunny.
No,
it's just,
it's just notes,
you know,
just this little notepad thing.
Like I've got one here that
I had to write yesterday,
but racial profiling and yeah,
I have a lot of them,
you know,
these are all things that
are just written down.
Oh,
they're all random.
Put them all in one file.
Oh,
do I put them all under funny and it's
a very low percentage of what actually
gets turned into a joke.
Right.
But it's like you gotta throw a
lot of shit up against the wall.
Do you record your sets?
I do,
yeah.
I record,
I used to use this voice memos
thing that comes with the iphone,
but I found that it
crashed a couple of times.
Fucked me and it's not good when you're
listened to it and go over stuff.
I'll use this one.
It's way more dynamic recorder.
No,
it's a.
it's a pay one.
You have to pay for it.
It was called the VRP full vrp.
Seven full years.
Your jokes and funny.
Well I just,
I worked for the one that
got the best reviews.
All the people that are like,
like serious fucking audio files.
This one,
they think it's the most
flexible as the most shit doing.
I record all mine through a
$1,200 a Sony Walkman move.
Really good.
High quality and such really
high quality and audio files.
I mean I'm a foodie.
Kept people in the deck when they tell
me they're a foodie and and my wife are
foodies,
but she has the fuck out of here.
It's like the sexiest
steaks and I love food.
Food.
Who Doesn't love food?
You'll call it a foodie.
I'm not a fucking
bed.
Pajamas.
It's people that are
like kind of shy about.
I always like or that's what
they long for more than anything.
It's just an element of life.
I'm not a wine know either,
but I like wine.
You know,
I'm an auction Genair we this
we need in this studio and man,
we need some wine.
We don't have any wine hideaway.
Big Winery.
We have wind.
Yeah,
the
wine list data.
That would be cool if
you had a really nice
wine rack on one of these
walls in here though.
I was going to say,
well we should get.
Is one of those wine cooler little
frigerator thingies and put some wine in
there.
I enjoy a little glass one while
while you're doing a podcast.
Like some podcasts.
It's a good idea.
Yeah.
Little whiskey on ice.
I thought it was gonna
be wandering here was,
I don't know.
I was watching a home and I was trying
to size up turn on the air because it is
hot.
It's sometimes sometimes you know,
you come to places and it's cold.
Well you know what it is.
We have a lot of electronic
equipment running.
Yeah,
he would have all that shit over there.
I mean,
cool enough,
right?
It's not like 80 in here.
It's like 75 or something like
three degrees above perfect
legs and
nice people in New York or eating hail
and those people are fucked.
Oh God.
Again,
hitting them again right now.
Right now I was just in
DC and man fuck all that.
Just.
Yeah,
I know I can't go back.
I was booking shows and I was like,
what am I doing?
I'm not going.
I don't want to go to Ohio right now.
So I'm like just west visiting man.
Yeah,
visiting in the cold.
Like,
like I was in fucking Sweden in January,
dude.
Well and it's cold as shit but it was fun.
It's fun to stay.
He'd drop in,
you have a good time,
get the fuck out of dodge.
Pick a couple of jokes about their,
whether
dummies
talking to joey ideas last
night and he was just like,
I just got back from Ohio.
The Sun doesn't work there.
It was daylight.
Cocksucker.
That's so true.
We're so spoiled,
man.
I know like me and the wife talked at
one point in time about living in Seattle
and there was,
we had a real discussion.
We even looked at a house,
there's a house that we really liked,
but I'm like,
you gotta tell me that you can
deal with this shit because I,
I can deal with a lot of shit
that you can't deal with it,
you know,
I don't know if you can deal with this.
Like you got to be able
to deal with clouds,
clouds,
and fucking Rad.
I want to hear any crying.
It breaks strong people.
I'm just sad and I don't
know why I take vitamin D,
getting a sun bed.
Shut your hole.
I don't know.
The last couple of trips
I've had up to Seattle,
I just have hit beautiful weather.
It's been sunny and great
at the last three weekends.
I've been up there.
I'm in Portland weeks.
Right?
And I'm telling people,
I'm like,
it's really great.
I mean it's uh,
seems like that.
And they get this dead look
in their eyes and like,
it's not like this all the time.
Just quit Portland.
Oh really?
Yeah,
because I'm the chief,
I'm the CIO and I still
want to quit real inner.
You ever go to the night you said that?
Wow,
that's like a
big gig man.
Doesn't make it a little bit of money
and that's not like your Tom Papa.
Like if you're talking
Baba Zali one time Papa.
If someone's a time Papa Fan,
if you've got to do it,
you got to do that job.
That's it.
But if you're a fucking
the CEO of a company,
like guess what?
Fuck face can get some.
There's a bunch of those
dudes waiting for that Gig.
The guy that's running foot locker,
I'd be happy to come
over and run the Nike.
You know the Nike store?
The factory?
Yes.
Well I've been to the Nike,
the celebrity center thing where they
take you to the place and they give you
the free sneakers.
That is the bane of my
celebrity existence.
What is the Nike store?
I can't get into the Nike store in La.
I don't go anymore.
I want it to go since the
beginning of my career.
Yeah,
I just heard about it.
You go and you get all this free stuff.
Yeah,
I've done shows.
I've been at Nike.
I just shot a nike commercial.
I cannot,
I can't,
it just,
something always falls
apart and I can never go.
You know,
when I stopped,
when I felt guilty about
wearing other sneakers,
I'm like,
this is bullshit given me money and I
feel bad because I'm wearing adidas.
Like this is stupid,
so I just stopped going.
I'm like,
I'm broke.
I can't afford it.
God Damn pair of sneakers,
everything online.
I love buying shit online comes
to you don't have to go anywhere.
I don't have to shop.
That's more time out of my day.
I don't have to dedicate.
I love sitting at Amazon like
with my ipad at night and going,
Oh,
I'm out of those eyedrops.
Bam.
We need more toothpaste.
And just Ah,
tape today about 12
rolls of athletic tape.
That's great.
I know.
I just do all the heavy stuff,
like cat litter.
Go into a store and a cat litter,
two liters of pop.
Anything that's heavy that I'm like,
why am I carrying this?
I'd rather waste gas
pellet grills that we got
from Green Mountain Grill.
I just bought a fuck load of pellets.
The pellet grill is.
Oh,
it's glorious.
There's a couple companies,
trieger Yoder,
green mountain grills,
the one we have and
what they are is these.
They take these hardwood
pellets now when you know,
like if you save you by like this table
is made out of oak and someone had a saw
this table down and when you're
sawing it creates a lot of sawdust.
They take that sawdust and they compress
it and the natural sugars just in
compressing it,
make these things stick together and,
and the pellets and you
could take the pellets.
You kinda break them in your hand.
They're not like,
it's not like a hard piece of wood,
but it is a hardwood.
And so you take these pellets,
he put them into this bucket
and it's super efficient.
Just like a small box,
you know,
like maybe two foot square of these
will last for fucking hours and hours of
cooking really.
And it regulates the temperature
perfectly and you can grill on it.
It works as a smoker.
You can slow cook food on it and
you could load every time you grill.
No,
it's loaded.
It's loaded for like out.
It's loaded for hours and hours of cooking
and then when you want more you just
pour some more
box.
So you put a state guidelines.
If you heat it up,
shut it off and you turn it back on
again and it takes a couple minutes.
It kicks on and heats up really quickly.
Tastes delicious.
I love cooking.
They have an app now that
you can just tell you how,
what your,
your temperature is.
Do it from your phone.
They also have other thing
that you plug into your,
into the meat,
like a meat thermometer and it registers
on the thing so you could tell exactly
what temperature your
food is when it's done.
Awesome.
Green mountain girls is the best.
I love it.
It's all gas at the Papa House.
Use Gas grills festival
doesn't taste as good.
I generally,
I like it
to grill on lump charcoal,
but I'd like to slow cook
things and smoke things on the,
on the Green Mountain Grill.
What's really not good as the,
uh,
the lid of my grill is the paint spin.
Oh my God,
this thing just happened to me.
You can't do that for a couple of years.
Not that the black stuff would fall on
your chicken and your don't know if it's
just a grind or you don't know.
Let's check into that for like two years
before Green Mountain girl sent me one.
Do you need to get a better grip?
Let's get new grill.
That's bullshit.
You guys should get groups together.
Yeah,
I have.
You know what a big green egg is?
No,
that's like a ceramic grill.
It's got like,
it's really heavy and the ceramic,
the fact that it's made as ceramic,
it keeps in the heat and a lot of people
like smoke things and cook things that
I use it mostly to grill,
but I don't have a big green egg.
I have a better one.
It's called a Kamado.
It's really beautiful.
It's big beautiful Japanese
thing with blue tiles on it.
But um,
I use that for grilling real stakes on it.
But anything that I want to slow cook,
like the other day I did a roast
on the green mountain grill.
Lovely.
That sounds good.
Photos.
Always lovely as I'm eating lean pockets.
I did my first Moose roast the other day.
Where did you get shot?
That bitch.
Where the fuck it is right there.
I got it in studio city.
It was talking shit
about him at the winter.
Drive talking shit about Mexicans.
Take it out.
No,
I shot it in Canada.
Here.
Moose hunting is like,
like the top of the hunting.
Well it's delicious meat and you
can get a moose and it'll last you.
I mean I have 400 pounds of
Moose meat in my freezer.
Oh my God.
Give or take a couple of pounds.
His face right there.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
That's his head,
right?
Yeah.
That
was the moose fellow.
He looks.
He's really lean right now.
Books for 400 pounds.
So it was a 900 pound animal.
Debone it and skin it
and cut all the meat out.
It's a lot of meat.
And so that's like 400 meals.
Is it really gave me or no,
not at all.
This isn't even.
No.
Moose is like a very unique flavor.
It's like,
and even deer,
good percentage of like diy or like what
makes it gave me is the preparation.
It's how people,
uh,
take care of the meat.
Like glands are really important.
You avoid like they have these things
called tarsal glands that like a down near
their legs and when they're in heat,
which is most of the time when
people hunt them what it's called,
the Rut.
And it's like,
that's when hunting season
is legal in a lot of states.
If you get that stuff on the meat,
it'll,
it'll fuck with the taste of the meat.
I get strong.
Yeah.
If it,
if it's,
um,
if it decomposes or if you let it sit
in the sun too long while you're gutting
it,
that's not good to me.
You can go bad if the organs
get too hot while you're.
While you're taking care of it.
There's a bunch of different
variables like the fat itself.
You got to trim the fat off of a
dearest guide through all this.
There's a guy named Steve Rinella,
he has a show called mediator,
sportsmans channel,
and he's taken me on a.
He took me on my first hunt and then I
started going hunting with a bunch of
different people ever since
then for the last two years,
which just get excited about.
Well,
I was looking up because fog rock
has been.
The band has been overturned here in Los
Angeles and I was just looking to see
what restaurants have it and
one of my favorite restaurants,
they announced that they carry it.
Do animal this.
There's a place right
down the street here,
right?
Like in the next town over.
It's called brandywine is fucking amazing.
It's on Ventura Boulevard.
They have the best Fagua.
It's amazing.
And people who don't like,
fuck Fagua Oh,
you're an asshole.
Why would you eat duck liver?
Well,
why would you duck
asshole here?
Overfeeding those ducks is that worst
and shoot him in the fucking face because
that's what's going to happen to cutting
his head off and pluck and all his
feathers out.
What's the humane way that they,
I guess now are doing.
Is it just like a,
there's a lot of debate about whether
or not it's humane to create fog and in
the all objectively speaking,
it is kind of fucked up that you take
this duck and you stick his mouth into a
tube and then you force feed them and
that's what makes their liver swell.
However,
the reality is when you go to these
places where they have these farms,
when it's time for the ducks to feed,
they all get close to that feeder.
They want that food,
you know,
they probably don't want you to grab
them roughly and stick their neck on it,
but the the best way to do it is to not
force feed them the best way to do it,
as to give them an abundance of food,
but you're going to get a smaller liver
than if you just pour it down their
throat.
I've never had it.
They just don't have the same.
They don't have gag reflexes like we do.
They don't.
It's not like.
I mean,
I'm sure they don't like being grabbed
and have their mouse stuck into a tube,
but they also don't like being killed now.
There's no humane if there's no
nice way to kill and eat meat.
Well is a humane way to treat them
while they're alive and that's where the
debate live.
But when the animal rights
people passed that legislation,
I mean you kinda realized like the agenda
of like Peta and animal rights people,
they don't even want you eating eggs.
Do you know pete on their website has
eggs listed to as a chicken's period?
Do you really want to eat a chicken?
Scared.
Pull that up,
Jamie.
Pulling it up because it's.
Oh my God,
it's so hilarious.
Now listen,
I'm telling you this from personal
experience because I have chickens.
I have 22 fucking chickens.
Okay.
And I eat eggs from my chickens everyday.
They are delicious.
And they are.
It's not a chicken's period.
Okay.
It's an unfertilized egg.
Look at that.
Would you eat at chickens?
Period?
Dm.
You fuck heads.
Are eggs come from
chickens administration?
Yeah.
So they have the underwear.
That's why a bloody underwear
where what kind of lazy bitch
can't put a fucking Tampon in.
Chickens were underwear.
They all do.
Every chicken does.
Candy protectors.
They all were.
They were maxi pads.
So stupid.
Have you ever cracked open and
ag have found blood inside.
It's like a scary carrie moment.
That's sure to make anybody gag.
Clean up in aisle six.
Hold on,
fuck wrote this one.
Pull up the.
Pull up the name of this
fucking dollar in writing.
Do they have a name on this thing?
Go all the way up.
It doesn't say coward.
You wrote a bad song.
PD.
Clean up in aisle six.
Fuck you.
Dumb ass.
It's like a Halloween prank.
Gone wrong periods or what you're eating.
Every time you fry,
scramble or bake with eggs,
you're getting delicious.
Cruelty.
Free Protein.
Okay.
My chickens are completely free range.
They wander around my yard.
I eat their eggs.
Nobody gets hurt.
My fucking four year old
picks the chickens up.
Okay.
These chickens are fine.
No one's getting hurt.
They're going to make eggs either way.
There's nothing wrong girls.
Period.
Anyway,
this girl is just not
having any fun at all.
I mean,
that's not gross blood.
It's his blood that my
stake is dripping of blood.
I don't know that fucking bitch.
Well,
most of the states you
either actually mails,
believe it or not,
their steers,
they're there a bullet.
They cut their balls off of.
You're going to eat 400
pounds of Moose eventually.
Yeah.
I give some away.
I've given some away.
I've given some to my friends actually
run a restaurant of Cuban son.
Owe you some moves to them,
told them to cook it and
tell me what it tastes like.
Tell me,
you know,
like she's a chef.
Yeah.
Mike,
what kind of preparations would you use?
Just like,
let me think about this and I go look it.
Tell me what you going to do.
Yeah,
but I've done it a
bunch of different ways.
I've grilled it.
Like I said,
I marinated it and grilled it and I
marinated made a roast the other day.
That was kind of interesting.
It was delicious.
It was pretty good.
Yeah.
You like sear it on a frying pan and
then you cook it over like 400 degree
temperature for,
but I was like about a half an hour.
Oh,
it's amazing.
Yeah.
Moose.
Well,
the good thing about it,
California to appeal ruling
overturning fog band.
Oh,
they're going to
fuck pulling to make
a reservation tonight.
I am upset.
What are they saying?
A little scroll up.
What is this dummy setting?
California California's attorney
general on Wednesday filed.
Notice that her office Twat will
appeal of federal judges decision that
overturned the states.
Two year ban on sales of fog was a
delicacy made from fatty duck and geese
liver,
California outlawed fog was
sales and production in 2004,
but for really abandoned place take,
take place until 2012
proponents of the band say,
force feeding of ducks and
geese to enlarge their livers,
amount to animal cruelty.
Critics of the band say it
infringes upon culinary freedom.
Effectively turning chefs into criminals.
Silly,
silly,
silly.
Fuck this questionable ruling.
California has the right to prevent the
commerce in such a cruel and inhumane
product.
All meat products are cruel,
inhumane.
You're going to have to go through every
fucking single taco bell and take out
all their beef,
all the pork,
all their chicken,
every burger king,
every Mcdonald's,
every KFC.
That is all animals that are treated
far more cruel than these expensive duck
and geese that.
I mean they,
they treat those betters factory.
All they're doing is
feeding them a lot of,
a lot of grain.
That's all they're doing.
It's not like,
you know,
this idea that this is like a uniquely
cruel thing and then if you ban this,
all the other things that
you see are not as bad.
No.
All the other things
you see are way worse.
They,
they cut chickens,
beaks off when they're babies so that
they don't peck each other's eyeballs off
because they're in such close quarters,
stuffed into these little cages.
That's all legal.
If they want to make something,
what they should do is
have everything free range.
Everything should be free.
Range pork should be free.
Range chicken should be free.
Range beef should be free range.
You should have an allotted amount of
land that you have to own for a certain
amount of chickens,
a certain amount of cows,
a certain amount of beef,
but then you're going to have
problems with coyotes because I have.
I have a coyote,
I've had two chickens get killed
by coyotes and one by my dog.
So fucking man,
man,
it looked.
They.
They find a way to get to them
and if you have a big farm,
you're going to have to have sheep dogs
that run around or some sort of dog that
keeps the coyotes away.
I mean,
you're going to have
to change agriculture.
You have to change lives
to it at that level,
that mass.
That's the only way to stop animal
cruelty when it comes to livestock.
And if they don't do that,
then they're hypocritical.
This is silliness.
This is so many food.
Right?
Exactly.
The only force feeding them in
such a small scale compared to.
And it's delicious.
Oh fuck.
Well,
so buttery going tonight is the restroom.
Yeah,
go use the restroom.
Tom.
Papa can go through that door
and do your little business.
I
just.
Yeah,
we got paper.
If you take a shit though,
warned us and keep the fan on.
He's a funny guy.
I never met him before today.
I didn't know he was in so many movies.
He's been in a movie with
Matt Damon before the,
I forget what the name of it was a,
but he's been in a lot of tv
shows and stuff like that.
He had,
he had that show.
Oh yeah,
that was a good movie.
He had that show.
The wedding counselor,
a marriage counselor
or something like that.
Yeah.
Where he's like,
what was it called?
The uh,
marriage marriage.
Ralph,
where he was like,
that's a job you don't want trying to
get people to fucking work their marriage
out.
Fun.
Break up.
Try again.
You're a new person now.
Try it one more time.
That was the quickest tinkle.
Every we do in blow in there.
Dude,
did you do blow in there now?
But I washed my hands and everything.
Wow.
That's incredible.
Fuck,
how the fuck did you do that?
Did you peer shit?
I'm like,
Oh shit,
here you can sit here.
I would never have shit outside of
my own house with twice in my life.
Are you serious?
Dude?
I'll shit in the parking lot if I have.
I really don't feel very infrequent.
Yeah.
Well that show the marriage
rough that you did.
Yes.
Was that a nightmare?
Like talking to people about
the relationship troubles?
No,
that part was okay.
Talking to the real people.
It was fine.
It was trying to do a comedy show
with celebrities that weren't funny
staring into the eyes of
Donald Trump or gloria,
stefan.
Oh,
you're trying to get some
funny conversation going.
That was.
I could talk to regular people about
their relationships all night and day.
What was and have fun and interesting.
What was the bay?
I didn't,
I never saw it.
It was,
uh,
it was,
it was a good core idea of Seinfeld's
that when married couples get in fights,
the fights will last
forever because you know,
you both,
you're not really giving
in and solving the problem.
You just kind of hunker down.
But if you have a friend,
you can happened with him.
He,
him and his wife were in a fight and
he had a friend over and he said,
Jerry said to him,
will you please listen to both sides
and you tell us who's right and who's
wrong,
and the friend listen to and it
says you were right and she's wrong,
whatever.
And he thought this was a funny
thing for a show for married couples.
Have there you have these fights at last,
their whole marriage have a marriage ref
weigh in and say whether it's right or
wrong and uh,
it's at its core,
it's like a pretty good idea.
But then there's so many moving.
He was like,
part reality.
There was a talk show.
Then you had three celebrities weighing
in and giving their opinion on it.
And then it just became
too many moving parts.
Celebrities are goofy idea.
Yeah.
Because especially like
a lot of celebrities will
pretend they have an opinion
that's different than they really
have just in order to be like,
to get Brownie points sort of sound
like it's the right thing to say.
Right.
Or just to
make noise on TV,
just to be saying something.
And then it became a booking
nightmare because the,
it went through Jerry's Rolodex at first
it was like all these really famous
fund people that he knew like how Baldwin
and Larry David and Madonna and all
these crazy people.
And then they,
it was,
it wasn't going to just keep
asking friends and stuff.
And then the next year it was
like the level of went to Helen.
It was like,
you know,
you can't get those kinds of.
The network wanted Madonna
every week and you know,
you're getting some road comic
or something like I'm in.
That part became Kinda wiggy yeah.
Counting on celebrity guests.
It's rough.
Like celebrity apprentice.
How long can they do that?
I mean,
they're totally out of celebrities,
right?
Celebrity apprentice.
Yeah.
My way to the store.
The other night I've looked
at the billboard on Laurel
and I don't know who any
of those ones.
They offered that shit to me when I was,
when we were rebooting fear factor.
And I was like,
what?
No.
Then they're like,
yeah,
you got to live in New
York for two months.
I would get the fuck.
And then I,
my,
I talked to my wife and I'm like,
it might be fun to be
in New York for what?
I can fucking just go to New York.
I don't want to be on this stupid
fucking show and have him say yo fired.
Is the money,
is the money so good.
That's why they get these people.
They offer good money.
It is good.
It was a good chunk of change.
It was real money.
I was kind of surprised.
It has.
It's been around forever.
You have for two months they were
going to give you like a real fucking,
a big slice,
a nice slice hat.
That's the only way.
I mean it's,
you know,
it's still not worth not worth it because
you're going to be stuck there and
you're going to have to do that.
But for people that are trying to
like really like I know Penn Jillette,
he found that when he did it,
like all these people,
like they got more people to
the show at the Rio really.
You know,
they have a weekly show.
They're there every week.
Penn and teller at the
Rio in Vegas every week,
every week and he kind of has to do
things outside of that in order to alert
people that are there and he said
it was very effective for that.
Yeah,
I guess.
I guess it's just a personal thing,
like I couldn't sit and look at Donald
trump and I just fired jetson that big
face and that
I couldn't,
but the marriage with was.
It was,
it was okay.
It was just chaos.
It was crazy producer
and it's crazy producer.
Those are great.
Wishes are great or not so stupid
ideas that you have to listen to.
It was crazy fighting with the
network and all this and saying,
oh,
what did the network?
It was supposed to be
like this nice little.
I show Jerry wanted to do this little
kid who's going to be like a Sunday night
show and just kind of like slowly
bring it out and let's just for married
people,
that's all it was.
And then Leno's primetime tanked and
they called Jerry and they were like,
we want you to save Thursday nights.
We're going put it on Thursday at 10
Seinfeld returns to Thursday nights and I
don't know if you remember
watching the Olympics that year.
They were every.
They were just kept pumping and
pumping it the greatest show.
Jerry's back,
the biggest comedy shadow every break of
the of the Olympics to the point where
when they had the final
ceremonies for the Olympics,
they cut it off.
Someone was in like mid singing made
Canadian song and they were like,
boop,
the marriage.
We're like,
oh,
this is not what you told us.
This is not the best
comedy thing of all time.
And they really came after it too much,
way too much.
We didn't even know we were doing it.
We didn't know what it was yet.
Yeah,
you got to let those things grow.
Right.
And they're like,
we were talking about with jokes,
you know,
getting the first draft on
NBC pumped up by the Olympics.
Totally.
It was so annoying.
Like I would watch the
Olympics and be like,
alright,
well I can't watch enough of these promos.
Letterman did a thing,
one of his top tens.
Remember,
that was the year,
like someone went off,
uh,
in not the Toboggan lift go lose or
something when flying off the side or
something,
and it was like the top 10 things that
he thought right before he crashed or
something.
And one was no more marriage
prep promos or something.
Did someone die?
Yeah,
I don't think it was the dead guy.
Yeah.
He wouldn't have done a
top 10 off the dead guy.
He might've maybe depending on where
his life was at at that moment.
Yeah.
Good point.
But it was a,
you know,
you just kind of get swept
into those things and just,
it was fun to have a show
for a couple of years.
Do you want to do something else now?
What are you doing that for?
Sure,
for sure.
I'm a,
I'm acting on the nick.
I have a couple of episodes
coming against the nick.
Nick is soderbergh's new
show with Clive Owen.
It's about a hospital in,
uh,
in New York in 1910 and uh,
it's really good.
Is it a comedy or is it a drama?
It's a drama and uh,
he's Clive Owen's May.
It's great.
It's really,
really well done.
This is it.
Oh whoa.
Yeah.
It's so good.
Modern medicine had to start
somewhere and soderbergh does it,
you know,
do a lot of stuff with soderbergh.
That really looks to me like
that scene in that movie.
The wolf man,
the most recent one with.
What the fuck is his name?
What's it?
Benicio del Toro.
Toro was the wolf man.
Oh yeah.
And they did an experiment on him and he
fucking turned into the wolf man in the
middle of the.
That's like one of them old school Lee
Auditorium type where they would operate
in medical school where
they do operations.
Oh,
it's so like.
And he's like addicted to cocaine and at
the end of the first season they treat
them for cocaine madness because
it's all legal back then.
They just a treatment for cocaine madness.
They give them heroin.
This is on cinemax?
Yeah.
I didn't even know cinemax still existed.
I know this is like,
this is like the only real be real.
It goes from this kind of been quiet,
right?
Yeah.
But I only did a couple episodes and I
have another couple coming up in the next
season.
But it's live and kicking.
Man.
This is a good show.
Showtime was dead in the fucking water
until shit like dexter now and now they
have a,
one of my favorite shows ever.
The fuck in the show about the CIA.
Homeland.
I love that show.
It's a fucking great show.
Yeah.
No,
it's good.
Silent Cinema.
I mean this is all they need to do.
Any was cutting up with a pink pig.
He was practicing Jesus Christ.
There's like some really.
It aired already.
First season aired.
Yeah.
Well the first season's
already received there.
There's 10 of them.
And there's so many channels now.
It's amazing.
But all you have to do like
a and e or like what is,
what is um,
even worse.
What is the fucking walking dead on AMC?
See,
what the fuck is that?
Who the hell ever watched AMC before
the walking dead was on madmen.
Madmen zone there to breaking bad too,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
out of nowhere where all you have to do
is just put out amazing shows and people
will flock to your stupid network.
It's crazy.
You can do it on Netflix or Amazon.
Oh yeah.
Netflix is a house of cards is giant.
I'm writing for a show on Amazon now.
Really?
Yeah.
What is it?
Uh,
it's called,
uh,
it's called red oaks.
It's about like,
it,
it's about a,
it's a coming of age kind of.
It's red oaks as a country club in
northern New Jersey and it's about a young
kid like working at the country club.
He's getting laid.
It's Kinda like caddyshack
kind of a feel to it.
It's art,
you comedy and um,
my friend created it and it has a going
and so I'm going to write a couple of
episodes.
That's incredible.
Yeah.
Well,
I know a lot of original stuff.
Netflix,
Bill Burr has his new animated show.
They wrote it already.
Well,
you could make something man.
Don't be jealous.
Make something.
They had,
um,
they had,
they wrote it and then it's going to
be like a year until it's on the air
because they have to animate the shit
out of it and it takes a long fucking
time.
Oh Man,
I didn't sweat shop to do it.
That's what happened.
That's what we did.
Me and Rob Zombie did an animated
feature called a super beasto dude.
You were hanging out with Rob Zombie.
Yeah.
What's that like?
He's a good guy.
Really good guy.
Hard worker.
Real creative works for movies now.
How weird is that?
That's good.
Really good.
That guy works,
gets up early and just goes,
really goes talking about like,
make something.
He's just like one of those guys like,
no,
we're doing this and
you're going to do it.
Wow.
And when we did this,
uh,
enemy,
it took us like five years literally from
doing it and animating and remarketing
and.
Oh,
I mean,
just went on forever.
Five fucking years effort.
How many horror movies is that?
Kind of direct it down?
Quite a few.
Four or five.
He didn't.
Two halloweens has 1000 corpses.
Um,
the other one,
a devil's rejects,
devil's rejects was crazy.
They just had Salem,
the lords of Salem's.
That's like some fucked up horror movies.
He does get dark,
dark and file it really flatter films.
And then you just like,
he's a,
you know,
they used to hang out with him and his
wife and my kids and totally normal
directed both my standup specials.
Did he really?
Yeah.
Rob Zombie directed your standup specials.
That's pretty fucking dope.
Yeah,
it was pretty cool.
That's pretty dope.
The last one we just were like,
you know,
people have given us money.
Let's,
let's make it,
let's,
let's use it.
Let's make it like show
business like we made.
We blew the whole thing out.
You know,
stairs are really just about the jokes,
but we just made it like,
it looks like a game show.
It was called freaked out.
Oh Wow.
That's on Netflix.
Yeah.
And it looks like literally,
like it's all bright and white.
Mike and yeah,
we just made.
He wanted to make like films,
like be creative with it.
Netflix is amazing.
Now I have my first
special on Netflix in 2005.
Oh yeah.
That was my first video.
Special.
Really?
Well.
Yeah,
and that was the beginning of like
the whole Internet for download.
Nobody.
Nobody really had the kind of broadband
to get shit like instantaneously back
then it was really gratifying to dial
up and 2005 or they had really shitty
cable or something like that.
But now Netflix has something like 70
million download or somebody million
customers.
Yeah,
it's big.
So think about that.
70 million people's spending
seven bucks a month.
That's why they're making shows
because they have so much cash.
That's fucking insane.
Money in sync about that every month.
Yeah,
that's they are there.
They have a lot of cats.
Why don't we make some shifts?
How much can that be?
A million an episode.
Not a big deal.
They have to have deals though too,
with like a cable providers and shit.
Remember they were throttling down there.
Netflix takes on $400,
million dollars in new debt to fund
original content and European expansion.
Wow.
I'll make it back.
Oh yeah.
They'll make that shit back in a month.
I have a great idea for a
Netflix special or movie.
Don't say it.
Someone will steal that shit.
You can't say,
I have a great idea.
It's not like I'm ever gonna do it.
Why do you say,
well,
don't give it.
Someone else will do it.
Just tell us when the shut this
motherfucker down and the notes.
You have a lot of great ideas.
Dude.
You're just lazy.
This is a funny idea.
I'm not really going to do this,
but don't tell anybody man.
What are you?
Crazy?
Okay,
go ahead.
so people have got rid of their cable.
Right?
And most people,
that's not true.
There's a lot of new.
Every year there's more and more people
that are getting rid of their cable.
A lot of my friends don't have cable.
I don't have a.
One of the biggest things though is
I'm somebody that likes to watch TV.
When I go to bed,
I like to have the TV on when
I'm sleeping with Netflix.
Every time watch you watch something.
It says like this window
pops up after the shows,
like are you still watching?
And then just turns off.
Then halfway through you
have to like wake up,
turn on the TV again,
or hit play.
I just want to make a video or a
movie that's like 12 hours long.
So you know,
for people that just want to
sleep and have their tv on
the good news,
the good news is no one's
going to steal that.
That's a good idea to you.
Have you ever.
Do you do watch TV when you go to bed?
Like do you keep the shear off?
I felt like a normal fucking bedroom.
What's wrong with you Brian?
But you know a lot of people that do that,
right?
You just go to Dr. Doctor.
Oh my God.
Get your brain examined.
The something wrong there.
You know there's something wrong with you.
She probably got a mouse
size to live alone.
You live alone.
I mean I think there's a lot of people
that watch TV with like have to have the
TV on when they sleep and they want a 12.
Our netflix show to Jello in waistband.
Just a great idea.
Sleeping,
not watching it.
Well,
you should pitch that.
You should set up a meeting
so they have another thing on netflix
where it just goes to the next episode.
After awhile it's A.
It's has this window pops up.
It's like,
are you still watching because
it doesn't want you to do that.
He doesn't want you to waste with.
So maybe have a really small low rez
video that's just like a normal movie
soundtrack and know they're not going
to do that to watch while you're falling
asleep and then the watcher while they're
halfway awake and it's you and your
underwear playing with your feet.
And boy this like,
shut this off.
It's the biggest hit for
people who are asleep.
No one.
No Man.
I'm telling you.
No one thinks that's a good idea.
What
I was going to say.
No one I'll show you guys
know what it will be.
The number one watched
the movie on Netflix.
Just for people that want to go.
It will be the number one wash for idiots.
People with head wounds,
people missing people.
Seriously,
traditional deficiencies,
the can't see straight.
They don't know how to work a remote,
can't find their glasses.
It streams and more eggs
all around the country.
That idea sucks,
bro.
Hey,
we have to plug our ears show.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
This is not happening.
It's on Thursday nights at 1230.
And you are on this Thursday.
I don't know.
Yeah,
maybe.
I think so.
We're here this week.
I believe you're on this Thursday.
Is that correct?
If not,
I'm on one of the Thursdays.
Is Better.
Keep watching.
What did you talk about?
Can you give us a preview
without giving away the story?
Um,
yeah,
it was episode about.
I Dunno,
there's a theme.
I don't know.
I know my story though was about,
um,
when I was in high school,
how I would,
uh,
I would sneak out of my house
to go to my girlfriend's house.
I
would come in for curfew
and then sneak out and uh,
I had this whole system and I would
sneak out and they get pushed my car into
the woods.
And then yeah,
put your car into the woods and then
start out and then Hyde Park it in the
woods by her house.
Oh,
they live it out to her house and then
push it into the woods so nobody could
hear it and not in the woods
and hide in the bushes.
It was all about saying goodnight to my
family and then going on and get going
out.
Yeah,
do do,
do.
It's A.
It's a funnier story than the preview.
But Ari has a great show.
It was the point in time after at
midnight already was on Conan last night.
Killed it.
It's just stand up.
Yeah.
Nobody gives a shit about Conan on
CBS store or tvs or whatever the fuck.
But it's such a good
place to go do stand up.
The audiences are great.
They do a good show.
It's just weird.
It's just because no one's watching.
It's just right.
What are the numbers like?
It's better than George Lopez.
Like $800,000.
Judge Lopez show was on after it.
Right?
It doesn't do that.
Conan first and George Lopez accurately.
It's below a million.
Yeah,
they tried to do that thing that,
that,
you know,
late night thing on tbs,
they try to do it,
but it's like people are addicted to that.
NBC,
CBS,
sort of back and forth.
Do you know what tbs is on your tv?
I don't even,
I don't either.
Never see it.
I could not tell you what the number.
It's like Sitcom reruns.
I mean that's what I
think of when I think tbs.
I think it's be,
I guess they have their
own shows to cooperstown.
Cooperstown.
Yeah.
But that was an ABC show.
It was cougar town was,
um,
you.
The problem is like whenever
I like baseball and whenever
there's the playoffs I
was going,
tbs,
I
gotta look it up and find it.
And you're not doing that every night.
Just there's so many channels now.
It's amazing.
And with things like Netflix
essentially with Netflix is,
is uh,
is like a production company that's
like a bridge to the Internet and the
Internet is where it's at.
It's like that is the
future for all this stuff.
Yeah,
all of it.
Yeah.
Probably with Netflix is though.
This is a problem,
you can't download it and
keep it on your computer.
Like you can't watch a
netflix movie a on a plane.
That's stupid.
That is a bummer.
Because they don't want you
stealing and then take a pirate.
A stream it.
Why not do it like on when you rent a
movie on itunes like you get once you play
it terminates in 24 hours.
Why did they do that?
Netflix?
Well they should,
but I think and when you
download something on Itunes,
you don't have a physical copy
that you could copy and play.
Like it only appears in the APP.
Right?
It's not like in a file somewhere.
We could find it.
Now it comes up on your ipad.
Your that Netflix.
Yeah.
They should do that because that's
annoying that you can't get something in
watching a plane.
I think that's whack.
Whack.
And it's when you go back
into piracy,
Dave,
Brian,
they're going to arrest people.
They put those pirate bay
guys and they just fucking.
There's some new ruling.
Got passed on the Pirate Bay guys.
They're fucked.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
They just actually
rereleased pirate bay today,
I believe.
I don't know what pirate bay is,
a new version of pirate bay.
Pirate Bay is a site that allows you to
find an access bit torrent files pretty
easily.
So like if Tom Papa is selling his,
uh,
his special online,
like if you do the Louis ck $5 thing,
they would just bit torrent the
shit out of it and people just,
you know,
somebody would buy it for five bucks,
throw it up on bit torrent.
And then a bunch of people
download it for free.
Like movies.
A lot of movies,
like the Sony Hack,
they released a lot of movies,
some movies that aren't even done yet.
She got files and just
fucking throw my line.
Oh man,
that's awful.
I use it for illegal books and pdfs.
I mean there's legal
reasons for pirate bay.
Austin.
Yeah.
No,
you could definitely get
some stuff that's illegal.
Like if you wanted to share things,
like say if you had a book and you decided
you were going to release it for free
as a pdf with a lot of people do,
you could just upload it and then
people can get it anytime they want.
And that's like one of the arguments
about what file sharing actually is.
Everyone says it's just
piracy and guys like,
you know,
Kim Dot com,
that dude from he lives in New Zealand.
I mean that they,
they've,
they are fucking that guy hard.
They took all of his money.
He's going bankrupt.
They mean it's,
it's incredible.
And it's because He created a mega upload
and mega upload was a place where a
lot of people downloaded,
you know,
quote unquote stolen or illegal files.
Was it stolen?
I don't know.
Why do you want your big show
and read by all these criminals?
What do you shot?
So alert.
Stay away from the Pirate Bay
website is we've gotten reports.
It has been seized indirectly
by the FBI and his logging Ip.
Mr White,
I legally use it only for
pdfs and you're going to.
Pirate Bay is an FBI honeypot,
a disconcertingly plausible
conspiracy theory.
Yeah,
that's totally plausible and it's
from motherboard.com of taken me back.
Motherboard.vice.com.
Rather back to the big
house with you honey.
Honey Hole.
And you and you.
Listen,
I gotta I gotta get the fuck out of here.
So let's wrap this bitch up tight.
This was great.
Tom.
Papa on twitter.
T o m p a P P or pa?
Pa.
Pa,
pa.
PApa.
Yeah.
There's no papa.
It's like dad's italian.
It's not,
it's not.
Oh,
it would be two PeAs if it was greek.
Yeah.
Pa,
pa,
pa.
Tom papa.
And he will be on verY soon on.
This is not happening.
Did we get confirmation?
Is it this week?
It's probably this way.
I believe iT's this week two and
I'm touring all over the place.
Go to tom.
Papa doc.
Compromise fucker.
Tore it all.
Mother.
Motherfucker,
Florida.
You could see him on the knick.
On cinemax.
Uh,
what else?
Anything else people need to go to?
Florida were going to be in irvine.
Nick for valentine's weekend.
oh shit.
Oh shit.
Baking the love his laugh.
I'm in Florida.
So you're going to be in Florida.
I'm touring.
Yeah.
I'm just.
I'm all over the place.
Good.
Googly mowgli.
Tom,
papa.com.
BrIan,
you got anything going on?
I have a new t shirt for preorder tea
shop squad.tv and then an ice house
thursday and friday.
And comedy store thursday.
You make your own sherlock's locked.
Boom.
Alright ladies and gentlemen,
that's it for the week.
We'll be back next week.
Uh,
I got a lot of gooD guests next week.
Brian cox,
the astrophysicist is
going to be on next week.
A lot of the people too.
I don't want to tell you,
but everybody.
I got some shIt going down.
Oh,
josh mcdermitt from the walking dead.
It's going to be on next.
Oh,
that's a good one.
BIlly corbin,
the director of cocaine cowboys one and
two and he's got a new new piece that
he's working on.
He'll be here next week too.
All right.
Until then go fuck yourself.
Hey,
put it up your fucking thing.
Oh,
we love you.
We love you to come on with this kid.
See you soon.
Yeah.